Hello, everyone!
Oh my god, everything's moving!
Whoa!
Yes, surprise!
You're now moving!
Whoa, surprise!
You guys can move now!
Look at you all go!
Oh my god, look!
That's me!
Oh my god, did you see it?
Alright, um, so, okay, um, I hate to kill the mood right away after you guys were like, Wow!
The moving background!
But, I have several life updates.
Some good, some bad.
Um, so, I won't say bad.
Okay, bad is a harsh word.
Okay, I'm gonna rip the band-aid off.
Um, but, okay, I'm gonna rip the band-aid off right now.
Um, I didn't tweet about it because, you know, yesterday was, like, VTuber Armageddon.
So, I didn't want to, like, add more to it.
Um,
so, um, but I'll talk about it here.
Uh, that's why we're on this screen because today's might be a little short stream today.
Um, but, um, um, that's why I put it on this screen because, like, I feel weird just, like, talking for- Like, I don't know how long I'll be talking for it.
And it would be weird that I'm just, like, a tiny thing on the far right side.
And then, like, you know, um, it's like, I'm gonna talk today.
I might as well be on a chatting screen.
Um, but anyway, uh, last night, uh, I had to take Dad to the pet hospital last night.
Um, because he was being really weird.
Um, he's okay right now.
Well, he's sedated in terms of, like, I gave him painkillers.
Um, but, I mean, that's okay.
Um, but basically, um, last night to take Dad to the hospital, uh, because I noticed he was- This happened- I- this was, like, two days ago when I started noticing something weird.
Um, he was very not himself in terms of, like, super low energy.
Um, and, uh, he was super low energy for some reason.
And I thought that was really weird because when I take him for walkies, he would love to play fetch.
And, um, two days ago, last- like, the night, two days ago, he wasn't really feeling like fetch.
I threw the ball once and then he picked it up and then later he's like, I'm done now.
And I was like, that's weird.
Usually you would want to play, like, a couple of times before you'd be like, I'm done now.
So I was like, okay, maybe he's just really tired today.
So, um, I waited until, like, yesterday, yesterday.
And then he- yesterday, um, I was like, oh, he is still very tired for some reason during walkies.
Like, he still woke me up for food and stuff.
So I was like, okay, he's back to normal.
And then, um, and then I was like, okay, so- okay, so he's getting better.
And he- he- whatever happened, like, two days ago, it was just a fluke.
But then, last night, um, I was gonna take him for walkies last night.
And he was hiding under my bed.
And I was very concerned because he refused to get out from under my bed.
And, um, I was like, okay, maybe, like, you know, I'll wait, like, an hour or two.
And then, uh, we'll see how it goes.
I'll wait for an hour and two.
We'll see if he's okay now.
And then I'll wait an hour and two and he was still under my bed.
And he was, like, shaking under my bed.
And I noticed he was, like, licking his mouth.
Uh, for those who don't know, dog body language, if they lick their mouth a lot, that means they're incredibly stressed or anxious.
So I knew, like, something's wrong if he's, like, licking his mouth a lot.
And he was, like, shaking underneath the bed.
And it was already, like, three- he was three hours late for his walkies.
And I was like, oh, no.
Like, okay, something's wrong.
So, like, I called the hospital and they said, uh, because, you know, it was, like, fucking, it was, like, 10.30 p.m.
at that point.
Um, it was 10.30 p.m.
and obviously, no, none of my, the vets are open, so, like, the only place I could call was the hospital.
So, um, I called the vet and they're, like, oh, um, it could be, like, you could wait tomorrow morning to see if he's better.
Um, or, like, you could bring him over right now.
And I was, like, I'll bring him over right now just in case because he's, like, he has a lot of fucking things going on around him with his, like, allergies and his, like, kidney issues.
And, you know, the fact that he, he was, he just got, like, he got served back surgery a couple of months ago.
Um, so, um, what I had to do to get him out from the bed, under the bed, is that I had to, like, lift my mattress up and that, like, freaked him out.
And he's, like, what's going on?
And then he, like, basically, like, got out from under my bed and, uh, and, like, went into my office.
So, like, and just, like, laid in the bed under my office because he was, like, freaked.
He was, like, oh, my God!
Like, oh, my God!
My little hidey hole!
Like, why is there light?
And then, so, um, that was, like, my way to get him out.
But he learned.
Okay, but to be fair, after I did that, he, like, today, he realized that he's, like, I know you're putting tricks on me.
So, like, when I do that, I did that today again.
And then he, because he was hiding underneath my bed again today.
And, um, and then he stayed under the bed because he knew it was a trick that I did on him.
Um, but anyway, um, anyway, so, uh, that was my way to get him out, uh, last night.
Um, and like I said, he wouldn't let me, he wouldn't, like, when I was trying to pick him, like, like, get him out from under the bed, I was, like, you know, letting my hand out.
He wouldn't even eat, like, even when I gave him treats, he was, like, he would just, like, he was, like, I know you're trying to get me.
So, he was, like, super cautious when, um, he was super fucking cautious when I was trying to give him treats, too, to get out.
And so, like, he was, like, I know you're putting a trick on me.
And then he would, like, he'll only eat the treat if I had, like, open palm on my hand and I don't stick it out of the bed.
Like, he'll only take the treat when it's, like, under the bed.
And like every time... and then when he sees my other arm move up, he screws back under.
Because he knows I'm trying to pick him up.
He knows I'm trying to like get him out.
So like I couldn't like get him out with treats or anything.
And he wouldn't let me... every time I try my hands get closer to him, when I don't have a treat, he like backs up deeper into the bed.
And then when I go to the other side to get him, he goes to the other side.
So he's like playing this stupid fucking cat and mouse game with me.
And I had enough and I just lifted the mattress out.
But anyway, I took him to the hospital.
And apparently, you know, like, you know, it's like emergency hospital.
So like they don't have a lot of staff during... late at night.
They don't have a lot of staff during late at night.
So I had to wait three hours.
I had to wait three hours until dad was seen.
And it was like...
Yeah, he was too smart for his own fucking good.
And basically like I waited like two to three hours.
Because like I said, it was like late at night.
And, uh, all the other, uh, like, you know, there were other patients ahead of him.
Like, it was the emergency.
So they were prioritizing, which was more, like, you know, urgent care, you know?
Like, you know, like, actual human hospitals where, like, you know, if you have, like, uh, you know, if you have a fever or something, or something, or you have a headache, and then the guy next to you got stabbed, who do you- but you came there first,
who do you think they're gonna see first?
The guy that just got stabbed or you?
Like, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
Anyway, so we had to wait like two-ish hours until we were seen.
And I felt really bad.
I felt really sad and bad because like he was... It was like, obviously he was not himself.
He was super low energy and he was like very scared and like timid.
And I was here first.
And he was shaking.
Like, he didn't shake a lot when we were like sitting there in the waiting room.
Anyway, but... So when we finally saw the doctor and like she like took him back in the back and like examined him and everything.
And then like she talked to me about it.
But basically, they think that dad sprained his muscle somehow.
It must have been fetched because like I was like he doesn't move other than for a fetch.
So they think he sprained a muscle on his neck.
Because they were moving his neck and he... Because I, you know, I don't know what was around.
Like I saw a little limp.
I wasn't sure it was a limp.
So they think he sprained his neck muscles.
Because when they were moving his neck, you know, like to test like everything.
He was like crying out when they moved his neck apparently.
Um...
And um...
They don't know.
They're like, okay, most likely it'll be like two weeks.
Uh...
Until he's fully recovered.
But they said if in two weeks he doesn't fully recover or he'll get worse.
The thing I'm scared about was that they said it could be a disc issue on his neck.
But like he said, like they're not sure.
They're not very sure.
But most likely they're trying to reassure me and said that it could be just a sprain on the muscles.
Um...
So I'm hoping it's that.
Uh...
But he is moving.
He is moving.
And um...
He is like walking around.
I...
Um...
So...
Uh...
He's okay.
In terms of movement, he can move and everything.
Um...
So I hope it is just...
Uh...
Just the sprain.
And it is to say like...
Uh...
If it does get worse.
Or uh...
If uh...
He...
Uh...
If in two weeks he doesn't fully recover.
Or like, you know, if the energy doesn't come back within like two weeks or so.
Then I should take him back earlier.
Or like within those two weeks to get a scan.
On...
On the areas.
So I'm hoping it's not that serious.
Um...
I...
I think it was because of Fetch.
Because he...
Um...
Even when I try not to.
He...
He doesn't know that he's a wiener dog.
He doesn't know that his body is not meant to do the things that he's supposed to do.
Because he's...
When I'm at the dog park.
He sees so many other dogs running around jumping everywhere.
And then he's like...
I can do that too.
But then like...
You know...
And then when other people bring their balls.
He chases after like the ball as well.
And I can't fucking stop him.
Unless I walk up to him.
And like take him away.
And he would like chase other people's balls as well.
So he's like...
Oh my god!
I can do that too!
And...
So...
I am hoping that it's just a sprain on his neck.
And like...
We know it's a neck sprain.
Like...
And we know the problem is around the neck.
Because that's where he's like...
Ow!
Owie!
Um...
But yeah.
Anyway...
Uh...
Yeah.
He doesn't know he's a fucking genetic freak.
Anyway.
So...
Um...
This morning...
I got a little worried this morning.
Because he didn't wake me up for food at all.
So like...
I slept till like 10am.
And usually he wakes me up at 6am for food to be fed.
And he didn't wake me up.
At first I thought it was because of the medication.
Because they gave me painkillers.
And they told me that when he ingests those painkillers...
He gets sedated.
Um...
So...
He gets sedated and stuff.
So he...
Like so...
And sluggish.
So he'll sleep more.
So I assumed...
It was that.
That was the reason why he didn't wake me up.
But I still like...
Like 10am.
He didn't wake me up.
And then like...
I got out of bed at...
And I was like...
Oh maybe he's still sleeping.
So I got out of bed at 11am.
And then I noticed...
He was still underneath my bed.
And I was like...
That's weird.
Well not weird.
I was like...
Okay I assume he's still in pain.
Um...
Because of the sprain.
So I...
Um...
I...
I like...
Um...
To be fair...
Okay.
I didn't mess up a little bit.
Because before I took him to the hospital...
Um...
During his morning walks...
I also played fetch with him.
But like I threw the ball once.
And he like ran for it.
And then after he ran for it in the morning...
Because I didn't think...
I didn't think he was...
There was anything wrong at that time.
And in the morning...
I noticed like...
Oh he's still a little tired.
Because he only got...
Ran for the ball once in the morning.
Like...
It was not today.
It was yesterday.
Yesterday.
Before like...
It was nighttime when I realized something was wrong because he was sailing under my bed.
But yesterday morning, I was like, let's play fetch.
And then I threw the ball and then he ran for the ball.
And then when he got the ball, he walked back with me.
He's like, I'm done.
I don't want to play anymore.
And I was like, oh, that's that's a little weird.
Maybe you're still maybe you just don't feel like it.
So you're still like tired or something.
But he didn't cry or whimper at all.
Like he was walking fine.
So I didn't see any red flags at that time.
But I was like, oh, there might be something wrong.
But then like last night was when I realized, OK, something is wrong because he was still under my bed.
Um, anyway, uh, today, um, you know, I woke up and then I got his food.
Um, and, uh, and I got his food and I went to, um, I was like, come on, food time, food time.
But he didn't come out.
And then I was like, that's weird.
You know, uh, uh, if it's the back disc.
I know he already had surgery for his back.
The neck is where I'm scared of, like, I'm scared about the neck though.
Uh, but like, uh, I'm scared it was, it's a disc on the neck.
So I'm just hoping that it's just the, just a sprain.
But anyway, so I was like, okay, he doesn't want to come out for food.
He hears me opening his canned food.
And then I looked under.
He's under my bed again.
And then so I put the dog tray to his dog food because I've got his little dog cat.
Like his, you know, the tray for his food.
And I put it under the bed.
And then he instantly goes like, om nom nom nom.
Like, you know, he's eating fine.
He's pooping fine.
No diarrhea.
And he still has his appetite.
But he's just like, you know, it's just a pain, you know.
So, and then...
Oh, turn off.
You guys want me to turn off the music?
I mean, I could turn off the music.
Is it too loud, guys?
Is the music too loud?
I could turn it down at least.
But anyway...
Anyway...
He...
You could turn it down.
It's fine.
No, it's... Okay.
Uh...
Oh, music is fine.
Okay.
Um...
Anyway, so...
So, uh...
He still has his appetite.
And he was like, om nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom.
You know, like he was eating it.
But he was still very cautious of me.
And, uh...
And he was still very cautious.
He wouldn't let me grab him.
Um...
And then I...
I like...
Grabbed his paw.
Because I wanted to...
To have his walkies.
Okay, that's why I pushed the stream back.
Because he was refusing to go for his walks.
So, um...
Because I had...
He was like trapped under my bed.
Um...
But, uh...
Anyway...
So, I grabbed his paw.
And he like...
Didn't like that.
Because I...
Like, I didn't grab a paw.
I was just like...
You know, I just...
I didn't grab it really hard.
I was just like...
I was trying to like...
Get to...
Both my hands around his body.
So, I grabbed the left side of his body.
Where his paw was.
And then he like...
Tried to like...
Yank it out.
And he started to win.
He was like...
No!
And I was like...
I let go.
Because I was like...
Okay.
I'll let go.
I was like...
Okay.
Like...
You win.
I...
Okay.
And so...
Um...
But then...
He was like...
He like...
He still was eating.
And then...
But he won't...
Like...
I got him out of the bed.
One...
Because I was like luring him out.
And...
Uh...
And then...
And then I tried to get him.
But he like...
Instantly scurried back under.
And then he realized...
He was like...
Oh, you're trying to get me out.
So...
Because of that...
He...
Uh...
He knew that I was trying to get him out of the bed.
Which is a safe space.
Uh, and so, like, after that, he would only eat if I put the dog food, like, fully under the bed.
Because he was like, no, no, no, no, no.
Like, I know what you want to do this time.
Um, so, um, obviously, I was like, oh my gosh, he needs to walk.
Because I, I need to make sure he poops and pees.
So, I had to, um, I basically, what I had to do was, I lifted the mattress again, but he doesn't care about that, because he knows that that's, like, a bait.
He's like, oh, I know that's a trick, because, like, uh, you're not really gonna do anything.
But little did he know, I was, like, fully, like, um, I was fully committed.
I lifted the mattress off my bed, and then, you know, the wooden, like, the, I don't know, the tiling wood stuff on, that, like, holds the mattress up?
I took all those out, and then when he saw me, like, like, take all of them out, that's when he knew.
I was like, oh shit.
Like, she's serious.
Yeah, the slats or whatever.
He was like, oh, shit.
She's fucking serious.
And then he, like, walked out of my room.
And then he, like, waited at the door for me.
He's like, okay, I guess I'll go on my walkies.
Like, he's walking.
Like, it's just, I think there's, like, a slight pain for him.
And that's why he's, like, not, like, he's, like, you know, there's, like, a slight pain.
Or, like, not slight pain, but, you know, there is a pain for him.
But like, he isn't like really limping or anything.
But I know there's like, he's like, you know, he just, you know, he's just very like lethargic and very like tired.
I won't say tired.
Because like, he's more so like, he just doesn't want to really move.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Yeah, so because I've been like touching her all around his body to make sure there's any like actual pain pain.
Because when he had his back disc pain, he didn't even like being touched.
Because when I like touched him, he would like yelp and stuff.
So like, that's when I knew that.
So that was when I took him.
When I was like, okay, I had to like take it.
I knew he had back issues.
Because when I was touching his back when when he when he had his first when he had his back injury, he was yelping and stuff.
So but this time, I was touching him everywhere just to make sure.
But he's not yelping or anything.
But during the hospital, apparently the vet twisted his neck muscles.
Not twisted his neck.
Gave more, not just touching, but twisting his neck and stuff to see how he is and everything.
And that's when he was yelping.
So I'm hoping it's just a neck sprain or stuff, but I will be monitoring the next couple of days.
If I do cancel streams later this week or anything, it's more so just monitoring dad to make sure he's okay and everything.
But for now, he's just sleeping right now and everything.
And I'm just making sure that he'll be okay.
I did close my bedroom door because I've had enough of him fucking hiding under my bed.
Especially because it's very annoying.
Like...
It's incredibly annoying.
When he's hiding under the bed.
So, like...
Just because, like...
You know, it prevents me from trying to fucking give him meds or feed him or walking him.
So I closed my bedroom door.
So, like...
I'm not...
Trying not to let him hide under the bed anymore.
Um...
But, yeah.
So...
There's no nerve damage.
Uh...
Neurologically, they're telling me that...
They told me that there doesn't seem...
Okay, I don't know if there isn't.
But, like...
When I took him there last night, they said there was no, like, nerve damage or neurological issues.
Um...
Because everything seemed fine there.
It was just...
Around the neck that they were like...
Oh...
Um...
There's, like, just...
He doesn't like it.
Like, he actually yelps when they twist his neck.
Um...
Yeah.
I might buy a dog bed that's, like, more so...
Also, Lana, thank you for the rage.
Thank you, thank you.
I might buy a dog bed that feels like a...
More of a cave for him.
Um...
Just so...
To make him feel, um...
More comfortable during the recovery process.
Uh...
So...
I'm planning on doing that.
Uh...
I guess, like, today.
And trying to see if I can find a dog bed that feels more like...
A cave-ish type thing.
So you could, like...
Um...
Go under in a dark, safer place.
So...
That's what I'm hoping for.
Um...
But yeah, that's basically the little dog...
The dog update with Dad.
Um...
Currently, he's...
I believe he's...
I'll check real quick.
I'll...
I'll check real quick what he's doing.
Okay.
He's currently...
He's currently just lying down.
Um...
On the...
The...
He's lying down where the sun is hitting.
So he's getting a little sun...
He's doing a little sunbathing right now.
Um...
But yeah, that's basically the Dad update.
Someone was asking how old he is.
He's seven years old.
Um...
And...
Uh...
He's currently seven years old.
Um...
I think he's like...
I have to treat him more like a senior dog.
Even though like...
It's almost there.
He's basically middle-aged at the moment.
He's middle-aged right now.
So...
Uh...
I have to treat him...
He's not that old.
Guys...
He's not...
Oh, he's old.
He's middle-aged.
Like...
He's...
He's middle-aged.
He's like...
Oh, he's old.
Yes, he's a hag.
Like...
But he's not that old.
He's just middle-aged.
Uh...
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
Anyway...
He's like...
He's just...
Going through stuff, so I do have to make sure to treat him more so after your cover is more like a middle-aged senior dog.
Um, so like, he is gonna have less fetch time, which he's gonna be really... not less fetch, I'll just make sure, I'm just gonna like, throw it really short, basically.
I won't throw it too far.
Um, so, because he's still, he really loves fetch time, so I won't take that away from him.
I'm just gonna try... the only issue is that he does like to jump for fetches.
Um, and, uh, he... he does like to jump, though, because like, if the ball is like, close enough, he does like, you know, he likes to jump and catch the ball.
Like, you know, as if he's not a wiener dog, and he shouldn't be doing that, but like, if I throw it wrong, he does that.
Yeah, uh, yeah, so, I could roll the ball, yeah.
Uh, Caleb, Caleb, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, dad, my beloved.
So, he's not designed for jumping, but he does, he likes to do that.
Um, um, anyway, um, uh, uh, but that's the dad update.
Uh, I'm gonna be monitoring him just to be like, uh, sure that, you know, he's okay and everything.
Um, and, uh, he doesn't, like, in my apartment, he doesn't do much, usually.
It's just the walkie's time that he does stuff, but during, like, apartment time, usually he's, like, more relaxed in an apartment, in the apartment.
So, I'm hoping for that as well.
Um, um, anyway, so that is the dad update.
Alright, well, we'll go to VTuber Armageddon now.
Okay, V- Oh yeah, before I go to VTuber Armageddon, um, I, during the, during the hospital stint, so, you know, I was trying to, you know, I was trying to, like, uh, get my mind off of, you know, the dad, uh, dad stuff.
I was trying to, um, you know, get my mind off of the dad stuff, and I saw, like, oh, Miku tickets.
Like, I was like, I was on Twitter, like, waiting, waiting for him to fucking be seen by the, the vet.
I was waiting, I was like, oh, Miku tickets, you know, and then, you know, when I'm stressed out, I buy stuff.
Like, um, so, when I'm, when I'm stressed out, I buy things.
I just, I retail therapy, um, so, while I was waiting, I was like, oh, Miku tickets, they're up right now.
And, um, sadly, I could only get standing tickets, and, um, cause, like, the only seat ticket they had was, like, all the way in the back.
And I was like, mmm, like, you know, I was like, ehh.
Cause, like, I'm like, if I'm watching, I don't know, I was like, if I'm gonna be at my first concert, and I, I know how...
Okay, I'm sorry, but, I know how tiny the screen is during, like, like, you know, not even just virtual concerts.
Like, um, during, like, you know, just concerts, uh, like, in general, and if you're very, in the far back, then the only thing you see is, like, you know, the screens they put on the left and right when they do close-ups and stuff.
So, I was like, you know, if I'm, I feel like, if I, you know, if I'm all the way back there, like, I feel like I won't see anything, you know?
Like, yeah, yeah.
Um, that's, like, my thought process about it.
So, I was like, oh, maybe I should just get a standing ticket, because at least, uh, uh, at least I could, like, you know, be close.
Cause the standing tickets are, like, all the way at the front, but it's still, like, a lot of standing area room and stuff.
So, um, I've never been to a Miku concert before, so I was just like, I was just like, oh, man.
And, um, I don't know, I just felt like, you know, I've done one standing concert before, and it was for Maroon 5.
This would be my third ever concert, because, like, um, like, kind of so I get to go there live.
So, and I, oh my gosh, I could barely, I only went there for my friend.
Like, my friend, uh, my friend was a huge Maroon 5 fan, um, and, uh, they were in Hong Kong, and, uh, and, um, and I was just like, okay, I'll go there for you.
And I was like, oh, what should I wear during my, uh, during my, like, the Phantom, of course the Phantom Thief doesn't count!
I was literally performing there!
Like, I wasn't, I was literally performing there!
I wasn't, like, in the audience!
Anyway, um, anyway, so, uh, so, I, I was so stupid, because, like, my very first concert was the, was the, um, Wonder Girls concert, and it was sitting, it was a sitting seat.
So, at, at that time, I was thinking, like, oh, okay, like, that was nice, I can, like, wear something nice, you know?
You know, like, go to, like, because we were, like, going to go to a nice, fancy place for dinner, before we go see Maroon 5, so I was like, oh, I'll dress nice, you know?
So I was wearing, okay, do not, do not, was it, do not judge me, okay?
It was a present from my, it was a present from my, my grandparents, but, my grandma, my step-grandma...
But I was wearing expensive...
It was from my step-grandma.
I was wearing very expensive shoes, but it were, like, sneakers, they're, like, sorta, like, sneaker-esque type, But they were from...
I'm trying to remember which brand it was.
They may or may not be from Chanel.
It might have been...
They might have been Chanel's sneaker shoes.
They were a gift from my grandma, my step-grandma, because she was trying to buy my love, but...
Anyway...
Anyway, so, but they were, they looked really nice.
They looked really nice.
Um...
But, um...
Anyway, they looked really, really nice.
Uh...
And, um...
But, like, I, you cannot...
That was the day when I wore it to the...
Because I never wore it for long periods.
Um...
And...
And, so...
That was the day I realized I could not wear them for more than an hour.
Because...
Because my feet were fucking killing me.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha The signing seats with my friend.
Like, she was just, like, screaming.
Be like, yes!
And, like, I felt nothing for her in five.
I just went there for her.
She didn't want to go alone.
So, she's like, oh, yes!
I'm like, yeah!
And sing along to the song.
And I was just like, my feet are tired.
And I'm just next to her being like, my feet's so tired.
Like, is it over yet?
My feet hurt.
They're not heels.
They were sneakers.
Because, like, I knew I was like, I'm not that stupid.
I was like, I'm not gonna wear it.
I'm not that stupid, but, like, that was the day.
So, that's what I'm worried about.
About the standing seat through the Miku concert.
So, that's, like, what I'm worried about.
Because, like, I was thinking, like, okay, if it's a choice between really, really far seats, then, like, I feel like, like, there's no point in going.
If, like, if it's, I'm, like, sitting so far.
Because I can't really see the screen or anything other than, like, the close-ups.
And so, I was like, okay, I'll just buy, I'll just buy the standing seats.
And then I tweeted about it.
And then someone was like, oh, if someone's taller than you and you're in the, and they're in the front, you're not gonna be able to see anything.
And I'm like, oh, fuck, maybe I should...
So now I'm like, wait.
Now I'm just like, oh, shit.
Like, what if...
Like, I didn't think about that.
You know?
Someone in the tweet...
In the Twitter thread was like, if they're taller than you, you won't be able to see anything.
I'm like, what?
What do you mean?
Like, that can happen?
I was like, oh, my God.
Why did I think of that?
Why did I...
Actually, I just got sitting seats.
Because at least, like, I can sort of see what's going on.
But then I will get a choice of not seeing anything.
And I was like, oh, fuck.
Like, I don't know.
So, like, that's...
Now I'm...
Now I don't know.
I already paid for the ticket.
So, like, I...
I don't know anymore.
So, like...
Um...
I'm like, I don't know.
I hope that I can see...
I hope that I can see what's going on in the front.
Like...
I don't think you can watch it online.
Not the Miku Expo one, right?
Like, the...
Did they have...
Oh, it's too late.
I already bought the ticket anyway.
I was like, there's streaming tickets for it?
It's too late.
I already bought the ticket.
I'm already set for it.
Like...
Oh, man.
But yeah, that's...
Now I'm already in too deep.
There's no...
There's no going back.
I already have...
Have the ticket.
I used my online therapy for this.
Can I even bring a box over it?
Can I, like, bring a fucking folding chair?
And then...
And then, like...
I'm full...
I'm okay.
Can I bring...
Wait.
What did, like...
What did they...
Like, they have to look through my bags, right?
What did they take it away from me?
If I, like...
Bring a giant ass bag and then sneak in a folding chair so I can stand on it?
Like...
I have to feel like...
I...
I feel like...
Someone's gonna fucking...
Like...
Like the...
They're gonna confiscate that from me.
Like...
I cannot.
Yeah, I just have, like, a fucking folding stepladder in my bag.
And...
I can't just take it out.
I'm not gonna buy a bag that transformed to a chair for a fucking Miku concert.
Anyway, I hope it'll be a good experience.
I...
I hope I didn't fuck up by buying a standing seat.
A standing spot.
Because it was literally, like, the only place.
It was literally, like, the only, like, seat they have left.
Other than the one that's really fucking far away.
From the screen.
So, I was just like...
So, yeah.
So, I'll be...
It's, like, November something.
November 8th.
The concert.
So, I'll be in Hong Kong by then.
So, yeah.
I guess I'll update you guys in November 8th.
If it was a good experience or not.
If I...
If I fucked up or not.
Maybe if I...
Maybe within that time span.
And I'll grow, like, three more inches or something.
So, we'll see.
Yeah.
So, I am a little worried about it.
So, I hope it'll be okay.
Because I did have a chance to buy the sitting ones.
Because they're the sitting seats.
But I was just like...
You know?
I was just...
It was so far.
Like, I'll show you...
No, I'll show you guys the map.
He's like, it can't be that.
I was...
I don't know.
It was like...
Because I knew how not great of experience it is to be, like, that far.
Let's see.
Hong Kong concert.
And I'll show you guys, like, what the ticket was.
All right.
I'm gonna pretend to buy a ticket real fast, guys.
Like I said, like I said, this is gonna...
That's why I was like, oh, man.
And, um...
It might be a little bit of a chatting...
More of a chatting stream than a gameplay stream today.
But, like...
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
All the sitting ones are gone now.
Oh, did I fuck up?
The only seats they have left are the...
Did I fuck up?
I hope I didn't.
Oh, my God.
Should I have just bought the sitting one?
Because all the sitting seats are gone.
Oh, no.
All the sitting seats are gone now.
I hope I didn't fuck up.
Okay.
All the sitting seats are gone.
So, I'm just gonna...
I hope that...
That doesn't mean I fucked up or anything.
Okay.
So...
So, this is the...
So, this is the stage, right?
And then...
The only seats they had left were the yellow spots.
So, I was just like...
I don't know.
They only had the yellow spots left.
So, I was just like...
You know...
Like, it's so far.
It's so...
It's so far.
Like...
That's why I'm like...
Look how tiny the stage is!
Like...
Look at the stage!
I was just like...
Yeah, you know...
If I...
They don't have the blue seats.
They don't have the green one anymore.
Boy, all they had was the yellow.
And I was like...
Okay, like...
That's...
It's so far!
Like, I'm...
Like, it is very far, right?
Like...
Yeah!
Better than standing!
So...
So I was just like...
And this was...
This was...
The yellow seats were cheaper than the standing one, too.
So...
So I'm just like...
Oh my god!
I'm trying to bring your own binoculars, see?
Um...
So...
I'm just like...
I should have just brought binoc...
Then like...
What's the point of going?
I might as well just watch it from someone fucking phone recording!
Like...
I might as well just watch it from someone that uploads it from their phone on...
On YouTube!
Like, at least that's closer!
Like, why the fuck would I bring binoculars?
Like...
It's the atmosphere!
So I was just like...
Oh man!
Like...
I don't know!
If that's the stage!
If that's how big the stage is!
Like...
Oh man!
Um...
Now you got...
So that's...
Yeah!
So I got block A!
The freestanding tickets!
Um...
And then...
I didn't get...
You know...
Any of this!
Because it was...
It was just...
It was gone!
Yeah!
So...
That is the...
Miku...
The Miku update!
Alright!
VTuber Armageddon!
Um...
I don't gonna say much about it!
You know...
It's not my place to say!
Because it doesn't involve me!
Or anything!
It does affect the VTuber community as a whole!
Um...
But...
I'll always say...
Uh...
Um...
That...
You know...
Um...
It just sucks!
Like...
After everything!
But I'm really happy to see that...
It does work in my heart to see...
Like...
Different communities...
From all over...
Coming together...
To like...
Do what's right!
You know?
And...
Bring like a positive change in the world...
Despite everything!
So...
You know...
That was...
Really great to see!
And really amazing to see!
Support all the people that were involved...
Like...
You know...
Support all...
Not...
Were involved...
What's the better way?
Support all the people...
That...
Uh...
I guess were part of it!
And...
Um...
Had to...
Uh...
Guess like...
What's the word?
Had the brunt of like...
Everything that happened!
Support all those people!
Um...
All the people that...
Did make it!
that were in the org that, you know, would have been in the org and everything.
I know a lot of people made some statements and stuff.
I- or that were affected.
Yeah, support all the people that were affected.
I'm not gonna say much about it because it doesn't affect me.
Like, it's not my place to stay.
It's not my story.
Um, but support all the people that were affected.
And, um, that were, you know, you know, after the whole ordeal.
Um, basically, like, they don't have a home now.
They're all, like, a lot of them are indie now.
So, um, so yeah, support them.
Um, they might not have the support structure they had back then.
Um, because, like, it's a very different experience.
It's a very different experience being a company versus being indie.
Like, I'm still, um, going through a- there's so much work when you're in indie.
And, you know, a lot of them have to transition to that now.
And- or, like, have to go back to being indie, um, to support those people.
Because it's- it's a lot of work being indie in general.
Like, it's a lot of work for me every day.
Like, I- um, I- I- I- I- yesterday, because of what was going on with Dad, I was able to get a lot of work done yesterday.
I had a lot of stuff that might be piling up, uh, today, yesterday, because of that.
So, uh, that's why I'm like, oh, today might not be a super long stream.
Um, just because, uh, I do have a lot of stuff to catch up on.
Um, but yeah, like- like- like transitioning to becoming indie is very hard.
It is very hard.
Um, and some people were saying, like, yes, I did donate to the, uh, immune deficiency fund.
Um, because it was a very good- it is a very good cause.
Um, I know some people- I saw some people were like, Girl, aren't you supposed to be saving money after the concert?
I know, I- I donated a lot.
I waited until my manager was asleep when I did that.
Like, I just- I know he would have stopped me.
Um, but it was- I'm a very spontaneous person.
Um, what's the word?
I- what's that word?
Not- I don't think spontaneous was- is the right word.
It's- when I do something without thinking, I like to- I do that a lot.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Impulsive.
I'm a very impulsive person.
Um, when I do- like, I like to do so, like, I won't say I like to do it.
It just- it's part of my, like, personality.
And it's bad and good at the same time.
Like, it's a double-edged sword.
I- I'm very impulsive.
Um, so, like- I always do things without thinking things first.
Yeah, sometimes I fail the quick time event and sometimes I succeed.
But anyway, so yes, I was like... I donated a lot because I figured it was to a very good cause.
And I know how much I make, and I know I have merch, I have brand deals, I have, like, you know, I just recently got my birthday merch, I got paid from sponsors and everything, and avoiding the Toki step successfully!
Oh!
No!
Oh, no!
You know what's funny?
Um...
By the way, I'll do a lore drop right now.
Like...
But...
Inspired Silent is the man- is the manager.
That's...
Oh!
That's Scatter!
So...
Oh, no!
Okay, so...
The funny part...
Was that...
I'll identify the manager out of all the mods.
That one was...
That's the manager mod.
Um...
So...
The funny thing...
The funny thing was that...
They didn't bring it up.
I know they know what I did.
But they pretended...
They pretended...
That...
Nothing...
Nothing happened.
They talked about...
Everything that happened...
During...
Like...
The...
During, like...
The new...
Like...
All this new stuff...
You know...
Like...
Oh!
This happened...
That happened...
But they...
They, like...
Purposely...
Avoided...
Mentioning...
What I...
Don't...
Like...
The donation I did...
They...
Ignorance is bliss...
They say...
Uh...
So...
Cause I...
I was waiting...
Waiting for them...
To mention...
I was waiting...
For them...
To mention...
About like...
Why did you do that?
You know like...
Ha ha ha ha...
They didn't say...
Anything...
I...
I know they...
Not they do...
But they purposely...
Said nothing...
Ha ha ha ha...
Yeah, so I waited until my manager went to sleep before I died to date it.
Because I knew they were going to... I knew they would have said something.
Anyway, so... But yeah, so... That's crazy.
Where was I?
But yes, it was a very impulsive decision when I dropped the donation.
And the amount it was, because I figured, like...
I know some of you guys were like, oh...
Oh, weren't you supposed to be saving money?
What about your finances?
So the thing is, I've been saving up to basically own a house slash apartment.
I don't know if I want to buy a house, but...
Because that's so much maintenance work.
That's so much, I don't know.
But maybe just an apartment.
I've been trying to save up to buy, like, a permanent place.
And, like, that's why I was like...
That's why that's, like, money I could...
I could drop.
So...
Um...
And the thing is, I figured that, um...
I...
I figured that, like, you know, um...
That money is going towards a really good cause.
Because, like, I can...
It might take me a little longer to save up for a place to live.
But, like, I...
The money I donated then...
Is gonna save lives.
And, like, I feel like that was much more important.
Because, like, it's gonna go to someone that really needs it.
For, like, if, you know...
You know, if they need, like, medication and stuff like that.
I felt like that was much more important.
And, um...
I figured, like...
Yeah, it might take me a while to save up more.
But...
At least, like...
Someone is gonna live another day.
Which is much more important...
Than, you know...
Living in...
Like, you know, I can rent a little longer.
You know?
Like...
I've been...
I've been renting my whole life.
Like, I can rent a little longer.
Um...
So, yeah, that's why...
That's why I donated that much.
Um...
And, like...
It was so impulsive that I even forgot to write a comment on the donation.
I was just like...
Boop!
I just clicked buttons and then it was done.
laughing Yeah...
Yeah, yeah...
I just...
Yeah, yeah, I...
I just clicked a button.
And then it's...
It was there.
I even wrote...
I forgot to...
Even, like, write a comment on it.
laughing
Um...
But yes, that was why I...
I donated to the fund.
But yeah, support all the people.
Donate to the fund.
If all my mods can link it.
Support the Immune Deficiency Fund.
It's a really good cause.
And it helps a lot of people and everything.
But yeah, save lives, you know?
But it was really nice that a lot of people from different communities came together for it.
So it was really cool to see turning something negative into something positive and everything.
But yeah, so that was my... that would be what I would talk about about the VTuber Armageddon.
That's all I'll talk about, about VTuber Armageddon.
And just support all the people that were affected.
Like I said, it's not my place to talk about...
If some of you were like, oh, did you... did you...
It came... I feel like it came as a surprise for a lot of people.
I had, like...
There was, like, a suspicious feeling for me.
But, like, I never... never, like, you know, thought too much about it.
And I was just like, we'll wait and see.
And see how it goes.
Like, and then when that dropped, I was caught unaware.
Like, I didn't realize it was that bad.
Honestly.
So...
Um...
But like I said, like, it didn't affect me per se.
But...
Um...
Uh...
And so...
And so I hope that everyone can support all the people that...
That, like, were affected in general.
Um...
Yeah.
Uh...
B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Lopaka.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Happy birthday, everybody.
Or just Lopaka, though.
Sorry.
No happy birthday to everyone.
Yeah, it's just Lopaka.
This is... He paid for it.
This is his super chat.
But yeah.
Oh my gosh, this was like an hour of... Me?
No, no.
Don't steal his birthday.
Hey, guys.
Don't steal... Today is his moment to shine.
It's his spotlight day.
It's his birthday.
Just his.
Unless it's someone else's birthday and they super chat it.
Then it's also your birthday, too.
No, it's not our birthday.
It's his birthday.
Oh yeah.
But I just also want to add... Another reason why I donated was because...
I know it's scary.
How you go from something super secure to suddenly having to deal with all this.
Especially when lawyers are involved, too.
It is a very scary experience.
And that's why I hope that everyone comes together.
It's for all those who are affected and everything.
Because, obviously, like... It's a very stressful time.
Especially when you're being thrust back into being indie as well.
And stuff like that.
So, yes.
Support everybody.
And let's hope that everyone has a very safe and very safe and very supportive transition back to being an indie.
But, yeah.
Woo!
Support your Oshis, everyone.
Surge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was my birthday recently.
Oh, it was?
Alright.
You better not be lying.
Because it was a fake birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Surge.
Yeah!
Woo!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
You know what you could do on your birthday?
You could buy my merch.
So, it's like...
We're celebrating...
Both of our birthdays.
Alright.
Let's actually play the game now.
Like I said...
It might not be a super long stream.
Because I have a lot of stuff to catch up on.
In general, there's no deaths in Epic Mickey.
So, we'll see how long I play today.
I don't think I'll be streaming for too long today.
But, we'll see.
We'll see.
Let me check how...
Let me check the sound for...
Uh...
Epic Mickey.
Alright.
I'll make sure the sound is okay for Epic Mickey at 2.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm booting it up.
Oh, I forgot to plug in my controller.
Where's my controller?
Whoa.
Alright.
Don't worry, Appy.
It's time to be...
I don't...
Guys, I don't think we're gonna...
Guys, I will try to get us the good ending.
But, like...
I don't know.
Guys, I was like...
Okay.
I was curious...
On how to actually get the good ending.
Because you guys were like...
No, you have to get the good ending.
Doki.
You don't understand.
You have to get...
Sorry, I should get my water gun out.
Which...
It's probably not a good...
Sorry.
My ink gun out.
Oh.
Okay.
So...
Um...
I...
Looked it up.
Because you guys were like...
No, Doki.
You have to get the good ending.
I wasn't able to get the good ending.
So you...
I have to...
I want to live vicariously...
Through you.
So I can see what...
So it's almost like...
I got the good ending.
So then I was like...
Okay.
How...
How hard is it...
To get the good ending?
And then I looked it up.
It was literally like...
Like a...
10 plus bullet points...
Of requirements...
To get the absolute best ending.
And I was like...
Are you fucking...
That is so much pressure on me.
That's...
I was like...
It's...
What?
And they're like...
Oh yeah.
I fucked up this one part...
For the requirement...
To...
To get the good ending.
And...
And then I got the...
The...
The middle...
Like the...
Neutral ending.
So there's bad good...
And there's bad neutral good.
And they're like...
Oh yeah.
I fucked up that one part...
That...
Where I had to like...
You know...
It's not very like...
Obvious at all.
So I thought like...
I was supposed to kill them.
But apparently you're supposed to like...
Uh...
Do something to turn them into good.
And then I was like...
That was just one thing they fucked up.
They fucked up one thing.
Like...
I was just like...
What the...
And then they got the neutral ending?
So yeah.
I don't know.
Maybe I should just go...
All in and bad.
I mean...
All it takes is one mistake.
Um...
Maybe...
Maybe it's too late for me.
I mean...
Um...
Uh...
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
How's fun?
Is this enough for a down payment?
And all honesty...
That was a very nice of you.
And wish everyone the best.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
How hard...
I feel like being evil is so much easier.
Why be it?
Honestly...
Good when being evil is just so easy.
And more fun.
It's too late for me.
Goes all in.
All I'm saying...
Is that like...
It's so much easier to be evil.
Like...
What's the point of being good?
If I can just be evil?
With less work.
Mickey...
Mickey would be very sad.
Mickey is a blank slate.
He'll be whatever I want him to be.
Um...
I gotta balance out the good with the bad.
You know?
I did a good thing yesterday.
So today it's time to be bad to balance everything out.
Alright, wait.
Let me go this way.
I sort of forgot where to go.
Wait.
That's a good ink.
And the other one was that bad ink.
Okay.
How bad...
How do I run again?
Is this running?
I'm trying to...
All it takes is one bad thing.
I got a reputation to uphold.
I got a balance this out.
Alright.
I guess we go back?
Wait.
I just skip the phone.
Go directly.
Only 10 eat.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Do I have 10 eat?
I mean, yeah.
That's like basically 10 cents.
Uh...
Alright.
Okay.
Now we have to...
What is it?
Well, you gotta get to the rock into Motor City.
But there's a problem.
The projector screen doesn't work.
Gremlin Marcus is trying to get him going again.
I'd say good luck.
But heroes don't need luck, right?
Bro.
Step bro.
Like half...
No.
He's my half brother.
Half brother.
I didn't know things were that bad, bro.
I didn't even know you existed.
I was born after they kicked you out.
How is this my fault?
I was literally born after he got kicked out of the family.
Was it him that I had to talk to?
No.
Who was it that I had to talk to?
Oh, wait.
It's the...
The cow.
It was...
Here?
No.
It was here.
It's Clarabelle.
No, that's...
Well, it just so happens, I came across a few.
Of course, I ain't giving him for you for free.
You gotta earn your keep around here.
There's a gang of bunny children that started showing up around Mean Street to cause trouble.
Just bring him here by City Hall and the pipe outside will suck him up.
Wait, is that a bad thing or a good thing?
I can't tell.
Am I a bad person if I take a mission from Big Bad Pete?
Am I...
Guys, am I doing a bad thing by doing the thing that Big Bad Pete tells me to do?
Surely it can't be bad.
Be bad.
Yes.
Depends on...
I don't know.
This is one of the things.
This is literally one of the things that you can fuck up.
I'm not Big...
His name is Big.
I...
I don't know.
This is a child.
This is one of the things.
Oh my god, do I take you to get sucked up?!
Guys, okay, okay, do I... do I let him get sucked up?
Okay, but that is subjective.
Okay, oh my god.
Sucking good.
Trust.
That would be evil.
I don't know if it's evil or not!
Let him!
I don't... No, don't... Helping... Helping make a bad beat is part of that good route.
They... Nookie is... For this bad fruit.
If I do a quest for a guy named Asshole...
Don't... Don't let it suck for science.
I don't know!
Guys, where is Clara... Oh my god, I forgot to give the pickaxe back to fucking Clara Bell.
Where is she?
That looks morally acceptable.
Just follow your heart and you'll get the ending you deserve.
What if I get the bad ending?!
I can't... Oh my god, he's going to get sucked by himself!
The fucking stupid children!
Oh no, we need... Guys... I can't... Oh my god... Who... Who had the pickaxe, guys?
Who owned the pickaxe?
I don't remember.
Guys... Is this... I need to know.
Is this bad?
Is this a bad thing to do if I took the children to get sucked up?
Is it...
Please... Please... Please, I just need to know.
That just means it's here.
Oh... Is... Oh my god, I came back for no reason.
Okay, let's go back.
No, you'll be fine.
No, I remember seeing it!
I saw it in the thing.
They were like...
Yeah, I actually got one of the kids sucked... I don't remember.
I don't remember if it was good or bad.
It was either... I forgot to get the kids to get sucked up.
Or... I... I... I... I... I...
Let's bring the music down.
Okay.
I'll bring it down.
We'll never know.
It's... I swear to god, it's worth a good round.
Jokey.
I don't... I'll never know.
I'll never know if I'm doing a good thing or not.
I... I don't... I mean, like, is it?
They're pretty bad kids!
Okay, we gotta go get the pickaxe though.
Did I return the pickaxe yet, actually?
Oh wait, I did.
Wait, did I?
I can't tell.
Okay.
Oh no, I didn't.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Alright, that's just $10.
I played the game several times.
It's for the good route.
Alright, let's talk to the...
Let's talk to the pickaxe lady first.
Alright.
And then...
And then, uh...
Is it good to answer?
Yes.
Thank you for the super chat, Cap.
Thank you.
Aha!
You found my climbing axe.
Now I can literally be at the top of the game again.
Thanks, Mickey.
You deserve these E-tickets.
Yes, I got the E-tickets that I spent trying to get here.
Alright.
Collect film runes.
Reels for the Usher.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Do I?
I swear to god.
Why am I supposed to be the one?
I literally have at chat.
At chat.
What?
Do I do it or not?
I swear to god.
If I get...
Oh my god, no.
That's not what I want.
God damn it.
Okay.
Am I gonna...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Get me out of here.
Yes.
No help.
Follow your heart.
I...
Follow my heart.
Do I help big a bad P to do a good thing?
We're literally just stuck here.
Because I don't know if I'm supposed to let him take the kids.
I...
I have no idea.
Okay.
I swear to god.
If this child...
If he gets...
He wanted to win himself!
I didn't even do
a R.B.
Where did he come from?
I...
We're...
We're gonna try...
I...
The child...
Oh my god!
I'm
so...
Wait there's another!
Fucking mission!
I thought...
Wait...
Why...
Why would you...?
Congratulations!
Congratulations.
Where did he come from?
Thank you for the super chat.
I don't understand!
Where did the bunny come from?
What do you mean?
Oh my god, I told you!
I asked!
I was like, I was like, okay guys, which ending will give me the good if I take him to the pipe?
Was it a bad or a good thing?
You're like, do it.
Do it, do it, do it.
It's totally not bad.
You should totally...
What happened?
Oh my god.
I think... Do you think you can handle it?
Oh, I thank god.
I'll get these in immediately.
It'll be okay if you don't get three out of three.
What if he just walks in like last time?
Yeah.
Looks like you're off to Timoro City.
What if he just walks over?
Because that's what happened!
He literally walked into it.
He tried... I didn't even know he was alive!
Okay, I just got here but I did an oopsie that may have changed.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How was I supposed to know?
He literally just walked up there!
I did nothing!
I swear to god!
I didn't do nothing!
I have to... Where is Petronic?
Where does he live?
They're like, go find Petronic.
I'm like, what?
There's a Petronic?
Where does this man live?
Where does Petronic live?
Please tell me.
Why didn't you save him?
Oh my god, there's that... I swear to god, if that bunny rabbit goes into the hole...
I swear to god, thank you for the rage.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, don't, don't go anywhere.
Don't go anywhere.
Don't, don't go anywhere.
Leave!
Get away from the hole!
Okay, guys, where is Petronic?
Oh, he lives in...
Okay, he lives... He lives in the Tomorrowland?
Okay.
Alright, you're not going into the hole.
I leave now.
You're not... Don't go into the hole.
Because I don't wanna do...
I don't want them to go to jail.
I don't want them...
I don't know if it's...
I mean, it's from Big Fat Pete!
But like...
Surely it's not that bad!
Like...
Surely it isn't.
Send the kids to jail!
Hahaha!
Oh, that's cool!
Oh, what is it?
Plutopia?
Whoa!
This is fucking freaky!
You see...
I don't like that...
I don't like that!
I don't like...
Hahaha!
Sorry!
That's like...
That's wrong!
Hahaha!
That's...
Why...
Why are you...
Why is this cat like that?
Why...
Why is this cat like this?
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
I'm 1 HP!
I was not paying attention!
I don't understand...
Why is he like this?
Oh, this is fucking freaky!
What do you mean?
Like...
You know what I mean!
You...
Hahaha!
I know you see what I see!
Okay...
But I can hit the cat?
That...
That was Pluto once?
Okay, let me hit the cat.
What's he doing?
Why is there a sausage?
Hahaha!
What the fuck was that?
Alright...
What the fuck was he doing?
Oh, this is a freaky level!
In general!
Yeah, this level is fucking freaky!
Maybe...
Oh, maybe it's under...
On the chimney?
Okay, yeah, I knew it.
I was like, it had to be the chimney!
Where else would it be?
Hahaha!
This is...
Pluto...
Pluto is on some shit right now!
Pluto is really on some shit at the moment!
I will find surely the path to a good ending!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank you, Papa!
Okay...
Big Bad Pete doesn't affect the...
Are you sure?
I did see them talk about the bunnies!
As a...
As something for the good ending!
Dude, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Big neutral Pete!
Okay, why look it up when I have a chat?
Alright...
Do I...
Guys, do I trust the one guy?
Is it one guy time?
Do I send the other child to jail?
One guy would never die!
Alright, Sunkyr Longo, take us to Tomorrow City if we can raise it.
Okay, we need to raise the Nautilus.
You put too much faith into us!
Saw the animatronic Goofy, he was headed here to try just that.
These cranes were erected to pull the submarine to the surface.
But then a thinner disaster happened and the effect was abandoned.
Alright.
Okay, we just gotta make friends.
We know how to do that.
Friend!
Nice.
With the power of friendship.
I challenge the...
Okay, we need this.
And then so we can get that.
And then...
Then we gotta...
Okay.
We gotta remove this, actually.
And then...
We remove...
This.
Okay, no.
We put this...
And then we remove this.
Alright.
And then...
We do that.
Okay, and then...
This.
Paint...
In that gear on the end of the crane.
Oh, this one?
Yeah!
I fixed it!
Fix it, Doki!
Let's go!
What are we supposed to do up here?
So there's something over here, right?
Yeah.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's Goofy's leg!
I got Goofy's leg!
Let's go!
Don't worry!
Oh, gosh!
Don't worry, Goofy!
I got your leg!
Got your leg!
Is it working?
I can't tell.
Oh, it has...
Oh, the other one has to work, too.
Okay, I think there's no fall damage.
Guys, there's fall damage.
Alright.
Guys, I think there's fall damage.
Guys, there's fall damage.
I don't know if you guys know that.
I hear something.
Oh, there they are!
How do I get there?
Don't worry!
I'll un-paint the area.
Okay, wait.
Actually?
Oh, this.
Wait, can I not?
Oh, I have to like...
It's like, inside.
It's somehow inside.
I have to get in.
I have to teach you this lesson, old man.
Okay.
I'll paint this.
Alright.
And then...
Actually...
Paint, paint, paint.
Okay.
And then...
Paint...
Oh!
Shit!
Okay.
Wait, paint...
Paint...
How do I open the other area, though?
I'll paint this guy.
Here we go.
That should get me my submarine.
Gosh, Mickey.
That sounds like a big fog.
I think you need that leg more than I do.
El, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gosh.
Okay, but where does this go?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's a...
Secret.
Okay, but how do I...
Free the man?
How do I free him?
Wait, where is he trapped again?
Anyway.
Oh, there he is.
Wait, how do I get there, though?
Huh?
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
I have more.
How do I...
Oh, shit!
Trying to figure out how to get up there.
How do I get up there?
What?
Must be a way to get in from here.
Must be a secret somewhere, right?
What's the secret?
We gotta free him!
Oh, I thought like there was some way from here.
It's a puzzle?
There's a puzzle here?
I thought it's like a secret hole.
Oh.
Alright, let's go this way.
And we'll make this man our friend.
Friend!
Nice.
Now he's a friend.
Wait, I'll just...
Wait, what?
What?
I can't...
Open that door.
You, puzzles in my platform game?
What the fuck is...
Um, I am here...
To...
I am here to jump, not to think.
This is my jumping game.
Okay.
I don't know, actually.
I feel like I did everything here.
Did I do everything here?
Yeah.
Like nothing seems like super...
Like super obvious.
Like how do I even get that?
Oh wait, I should grab this though.
Yay!
The base of those pillars seem odd?
Which one?
There's so many.
They all seem very odd.
Oh, these?
I think I can paint that though.
They don't seem paintable, see?
Open up.
Go over the giant stone head?
This guy?
What about him?
Ow.
What?
Your eyes.
I got your eyes.
A layer with an orange base.
I'm gonna go up.
Give me your eyes!
No?
Oh, there's something that gets thin?
That's a lot- Oh, this?
Oh!
God!
Okay, that's like...
Not obvious to me.
That...
That was...
Not obvious at all.
Oh, that's cool though.
I guess if it's orange, I can thin it?
That is secret.
And then I thin this.
That's right, you're free now.
That's right, I'm a fucking hero.
I have no idea what I did.
Alright.
What did I do?
Wait, what does that gear do?
Wait, what?
What did that gear do?
What is it turning?
What are you turning?
I don't...
What are you doing?
The more vibrant the object, the more...
Oh!
The other door!
That door?
That's a lie.
No, it didn't.
Oh!
I know!
That thing!
That leg!
Yay!
Wait, was that a bad thing?
Did I do a bad thing?
Oh no, did I do a...
No.
No, it can't be.
No, I didn't.
No.
I can't...
I can't tell!
I can't tell if I'm evil or not!
Did I ruin some ancient artifact?
No, there's no way.
There's no way.
I can't...
I ruined like thousands of years of...
History?
No.
No, there's no way.
There's no way.
It can't be me.
It can't...
No.
You must.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm a bad person or not!
Okay.
There is another one.
There is...
It's serious.
It's eyes.
I don't...
I don't know why that...
If I do it again, that's the question.
I think I do.
Oh yes, okay, this is a good thing.
This is a good thing, guys.
There's another gear.
It had to be done!
What the fuck was...
Oh, now I got the treasure.
It had to be...
Guys, if...
If...
If the British can do it, so can I.
Guys, the British weren't punished.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Alright, let's go open this chest.
What do I get?
Yay!
I got a silver pin.
Okay.
Maybe that wasn't worth it.
Maybe like...
Um...
Vandalizing the ancient ruins was not worth a spin.
Maybe...
But for my collectible.
Toki, it's all about the collectible though.
Okay.
Disney adults will do anything for the pin.
I swear I'm different.
I swear.
What is he doing?
Whoa!
Let's go!
Okay, we gotta go on this car.
Be angry!
That's right!
Use your rage for bad!
Use your rage for an unhealthy outlet!
Let's do it!
Where is he?
Where did our guy go?
Oh!
He's fighting him now!
Okay, wait.
What the fuck is going on over there?
Yeah, we gotta go this way though.
There's some stuff I have to get.
Money!
Guys, I need this to pay the troll till.
Alright.
Alright, let's go watch this fight.
Fight!
Whoa!
Oh wait, that would take me up top.
But I need him to do that again.
Oh, that's so smart!
Okay, I like that.
I like that for my Pathformer game.
Yay!
Yeah, rock him, sock him.
I like that level.
That was cute!
That was a cute level!
Alright, I'm in the submarine.
We're resurfacing, Mickey.
This is the gateway into Tomorrow Cities proper.
Uh-huh!
Oh boy!
Can't wait to commit more murders!
And Val's will open the way for us.
You'll have to find all of them.
Okay.
I mean, that's pretty easy.
Oh boy!
Spinners are a tough form of...
That painted shell is like armor.
You can melt their...
But to damage them, you have to get close and use your spin move after they flip over.
Can't be turned.
They're programmed to not like you.
Wait!
No!
They're an anti!
See me!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
A little bot had see...
No!
But I'm so witty and charismatic!
Hahaha!
Okay, let's go...
I feel like there's something back here.
It was telling me to go back here.
There has to be something back here.
Because forward is the right way to go.
Alright.
What's in here?
Oh, is that Goofy?
No, it's just a regular chest.
Wait, why the fuck was...
Is that it?
You're no Goofy?
Aww.
There's no Goofy part.
Wait.
Yes, in the...
In the Mickey Mouse universe, aliens are real.
Okay, I'll go this way.
Alright.
Where is Donald Duck?
I mean, he's still a beloved character.
So, like...
He's not here.
Because it's for all the forgotten characters.
All the...
All the bad ones.
There we go.
Wait, that was like a full...
Get out of here.
That's right.
What are you trying to do?
Turn back?
Get back over here.
You think I'm gonna...
That's right.
Yeah, get your ass out of here.
Get out!
That's right.
No bots allowed.
There can only be one AI here and that's me.
Click, don't run from me.
I know what you are.
I like the theory.
The AI theory.
That like...
The more AI...
The more like people use AI...
It was for like...
For like art.
The more it like cannibalize itself.
And start producing bad art.
Because it's like copying themselves over and...
Because there's just so much AI art now.
That they just start copying each other.
There.
And then there's...
That's the whole...
The yellow tint thing.
Yeah, so like...
That's why AI art now has like a yellow tint.
Because of the Ghibli thing.
Because they like cannibalize itself.
Where do I go?
Whoa.
I thought that was really interesting.
Yeah, AI inbreeding.
So they're literally inbreeding right now.
Okay, that's really fucking funny if you think about it.
Inbred AI.
Oh my god.
They're actually inbred.
That's like a crazy...
AI says.
Don't call it that.
What else are they?
And they're just...
Where the fuck do I go?
I'm so confused.
I'm scared of this.
Or maybe I put this platform on.
And then...
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, there we go.
Now I'm up here.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Friend, friend, friend, friend.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Okay, friend.
Oh, there we go.
One final gear to go.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I'll just cover this up.
Wait, I can't.
Oh, shit.
No.
Don't go in there.
Don't do...
Okay.
That's...
I thought he was gonna go in there.
Don't do it.
You have so much to live for.
No.
Okay.
Let's see.
That's sweet.
Oh, wait.
Now it's secret.
And I got this too.
Yay.
I shut down the valves.
You were hoped.
Like the very slow.
Yeah.
Wait, wait.
I know how to...
Wait, did he actually go in it?
Wait, where did he go?
Wait a minute.
Where did he go?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I know what to do.
Don't do it.
You have so much more to live for.
Don't...
Don't do it.
You have so much...
Don't worry.
I'll just do that.
You have so much to live.
Don't do it.
You have so...
What if I...
Don't do it.
He has so much to live for.
Guys.
I hope he doesn't do it.
I...
Alright, let's see.
Look.
I...
I'm a hero.
I stopped him.
I stopped it.
I'm a hero.
Oh, the Great Big Tomorrow exhibit.
Whoa, what's that?
Mr. Robot has been working on cleaning up for a while.
I'm really excited to see you again.
It's been such a long time.
Oh no, a slobber!
Defeat the slobber?
Friend?
Means the block really wants to stop you.
The sooner-in-claw's, dude.
He's rambo is trying to heal.
When he starts out, let him have it with pain...Oh, okay, so, I can.
Don't worry sir!
I shall save you!
With the power of friendship!
Okay.
We have to start inhaling.
Inhale!
Oh my God!
Oh shit!
Frick!
Ah!
No!
Care Bear Countdown, 4, 3, 2...
Am I doing anything?
Okay, I am.
He is inhaling my Friendship Beam.
Friendship Beam!
Become my friend!
Through force, I shall be your friend.
Because force friendship is the best type of friendship.
Yummy friendship.
Oh look, the carousel is reactivated.
Yay!
Miku Miku Bee!
Behold, the glory of what wasteland can be.
Beings such as you generously apply paint to rebuild, restore, and improve.
Manipulation, my beloved.
For levels such as yours, reshape the land into a better place.
Thank you for taking care of that slobber.
I sealed a great big tomorrow when I heard of the impending attack.
The slobber taken care of, I used my last bit of energy to reactivate the carousel.
The television will be useful to you.
I promise!
Enjoy!
Yay!
I got a TV!
Temporary TV.
Everyone's watching.
He only dropped one TV at a time and they don't last long.
Scroll through your sketches and activate a sketch with LB.
Oh!
Oh, it's like a power.
But use them with care.
Each check works just one.
Oh, shit!
Don't worry, I'll hoard it all until Epic Miku 2.
There's a power in places like this.
As if any presbyes decide not to use it, they will put it away.
Wait!
I don't wanna use my TV!
Is he okay?
Oh, he has plenty!
Okay, okay, I can refill my TVs here.
Okay, that's good to know.
Wait, what happened to my... my friend?
What happened to my new best friend that I forced him to be my friend?
It's not like forced if he wanted it, guys.
He wanted to be my friend, guys.
Look at him.
He had that big ass heart at the end.
When?
TV.
Okay, give me...
Give me...
Give me another TV.
Wait, no.
I want TV.
Where's my TV?
Where's my TV sketch?
He literally said he'd give me a TV sketch.
My god, he fucking liar!
He's holding out!
Where's the TV sketch?
Okay.
Away we go!
Where am I?
Is this the place?
Oh, he took me to the other side.
That's not as impressive.
He just took me to the other side.
Okay.
Alright, let's grab this sketch.
And then...
Okay.
Off we go.
Oh, there's more.
Oh, okay.
We just have to go through this portal.
Yes.
Scene 2.
Thank you.
Donnie, thank you to the super chat.
Wait.
Oh, yes.
I knew it.
There's always, like, something hidden in the back.
Oh, I can't even get there.
Maybe, like...
I have to jump on this.
Right?
Okay, the timing for this is hard.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, the timing for that was really hard, actually.
How do I get down, though?
What?
How the fuck do I get down from there?
Okay.
Oh!
Because it's red!
I should be able to.
Right?
Come on.
Let me...
Okay, I don't need...
They think I don't need that $10.
That $10 is not as much as they think I need.
Like, I'm not that desperate.
Okay, I mean...
I'm not that desperate.
I swear to God.
I...
Why does he look at me like that?
Goofy?
Not Goofy.
Pluto!
I need it.
Need it.
Ask you about something, Pluto!
What was that?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
I was like, why does he look at me like that?
I'm uncomfortable with Pluto.
Pluto!
I'm...
That's a freaky fucking cat.
Let's grab the tape.
Oh my god.
Pluto!
Daddy's concerned, Pluto!
What's going on?
Okay.
Nice, I got the sausages.
It's okay.
He has a type.
And what is this type?
What are you trying to say?
What is this type?
Guys, what are you trying to say about my dog?
What...
There's like a film over there.
I'll grab it.
Alright.
Let's go grab...
How do I get that film though?
Oh, I can make that jump.
Yeah.
Oh, I...
Oh, it was a secret?
Okay.
I was gonna say, there's no way I'd make that.
Let the boy dream.
That's why it's in his dreams only.
That's why...
It's his thoughts that he keeps it himself only.
Oh my god, Litte!
Thank you for the...
Super!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it, Litte!
Thank you for being so kind, Doki.
That's why you're the best.
Thank you, Litte!
Hey, you'll have to power up the people mover.
Allow you to access space voyage.
The rocker ride is broken too.
See what you can do to repair it.
I'm sure there'll be someone around here who can assist you.
Good luck!
Okay.
Wait, are those...
Oh, those are the ones that hate me no matter what.
So like, I can't do anything about it.
Okay.
Nobody saw that.
Guys, I swear to god, that's not an evil thing to do, guys.
I swear to god.
That's not evil!
It's not evil!
I swear, it's not evil, guys.
It's not evil.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, there's so many of them.
Where did I bring them to?
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
They're fucking everywhere.
Oh my god, are they just...
Did they just come back infinitely?
Okay.
Are you serious?
Get back over here, get back over here.
I see your fucking booty.
Get back over here!
Yeah, I need to get this guy out, though.
Okay, he's out.
He's out.
God damn it!
No!
No, let me hit him!
Let me hit him!
Okay, the enemies are getting a little tougher now.
Okay, he's trying to...
Trying to...
Not be naked.
Be naked!
Can't be friends with you.
Be naked, people.
Oh my god, it's forever.
Oh, it is forever.
Can I like...
Destroy it?
Oh my god, I can't!
Okay, now that I know...
It's forever.
Okay, I gotta figure out how to...
Get this out then.
Oh, TV tab.
TV.
I have infinite antis.
Okay.
Does that stop it?
Oh, I think it does, right?
I think it does.
Yeah, I think I stopped it.
Okay, I...
Did not stop it.
Never mind.
Never mind, guys.
It did not stop.
Oh!
It only stops for a little bit.
Oh, I see.
I see.
It's not forever.
The people mover must be functional to open the doors blocking space forage.
We need to see to activate the people mover.
Oh, I have to...
It's time!
Okay.
I need to figure out where the three is.
Okay, one, two, three.
Okay, I found the three.
Okay, I have three just...
I got three too.
Okay.
I got it.
I gotta go.
Go!
Okay, two!
Wait, what?
Oh, shit!
Oh, is it already powered up?
Oh, okay.
Okay, this level is confusing.
Okay, this level is so confusing, actually.
I'm a little confused.
Oh!
You can only place one.
Oh, they stayed...
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I get it now.
I get it.
Okay.
This area is a little confusing, though.
Can I make it over here?
How do I make it over there?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
From there...
Okay, it's a parkour too.
Okay, it's a little parkour area.
How do I get there?
Ooh.
Maybe...
If I erase this...
And then...
No, there's nothing there.
What?
It's fucking...
Oh, friend.
Friend.
Oh, they're wearing Tron costumes!
I just noticed it!
Oh, that's cute.
Wait, friend.
You guys are supposed to be best friends forever.
Oh, that's cute!
They're wearing Tron costumes.
Anything down here?
I knew it.
I knew you weren't real.
I knew you weren't real!
And how do I do that jump?
Wait, can I make that?
Oh, yeah.
No!
It was close, though.
It was close.
It almost looked like I could make it.
Where the fuck am I going?
Where am I?
I don't even know where I am.
Oh, my...
It almost looked so cool, guys.
It really almost looked so cool.
It really did.
I swear to God, it would have been so cool.
If I didn't fuck it up.
Where the fuck am I?
Where did I go?
Where is...
Where am I?
Where did I go?
I'm inside now?
How did I get here?
Oh, nice!
Nice job, Mickey.
Oh, shit!
I did it!
Oh, I got a shortcut!
I actually got a shortcut!
Nice!
Hello, guys.
I wasn't supposed to do that.
My friend Nova is really good with rides like the people movie.
I take care of the ride, no doubt.
I could work with those things myself, too.
Dangerous.
Okay, there's friends here.
You know, you could break your friend out.
You know, you could break your...
You know, you could help your friend out there, too.
Like, did you really need me to break your friend out?
Like, he was right there!
He was...
He was right there.
But he's like, yeah, this is where he is.
I'm like, cool.
Alright.
But that's too much work.
Thanks for setting me free.
I thought I had done everything already.
I figured I'd make it up here to release me.
But you did.
Here, let me disable this dangerous people mover.
Follow the tracks out through the gate.
Alright, nice.
What's the plan?
Activating the people mover, then.
Okay, I need to figure out how to get to this side.
Because there's a...
There's a part there.
I see that, right?
That's the goofy part.
How do I get there?
That's the question.
Maybe like...
Oh, maybe up here.
Okay, wait.
I figured it out.
It's too hot.
Alright, okay.
I thought I was gonna die there.
I gotta get back up.
Grab some...
Ten dollars.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Cause I think that's a goofy part right there.
And we gotta save Goofy.
If we wanna get a good ending.
Alright.
Okay.
I got this.
Parkour!
Okay.
Now we gotta figure this out.
Now...
Now we just gotta figure out how to do this.
I'm Goofing it right now.
Okay.
How the fuck...
How do you do this?
Alright.
Maybe like...
Up top?
What?
It's like...
I don't think I can make that jump over there.
But can I...
Do this?
And just...
Oh.
No!
No, it's transparent.
It's not even...
They don't have any like...
Colliders on that shit.
Or that.
I know my gaming term.
Fuck.
Okay.
I'm...
I'm pretty sure this is not how to do this.
It's not wrong.
How the fuck do I get to that side?
There's a floor?
This thing?
Help me activate it.
This is it.
Okay.
But what if that...
Okay, guys.
That's not how you do it, guys.
I don't...
How the fuck do I activate this shit?
Hello?
Yeah, but where is the activation?
Is it down here?
Maybe it's down here?
Never went down this area.
Is it this?
No.
No, it can't be.
It's like this area is like...
Where I was supposed to go to go up.
Oh, there's some gears near the...
Okay.
In the...
Sorry.
Okay, let's go to that.
Oh my god.
You have to think now.
Alright.
Where are the gears?
Gear.
Oh, gear.
Wait, that was a lot.
There was no gear.
That was a fucking lie.
What the fuck?
There's no gears anywhere.
People who do that just lie on the internet?
Oh, there's a...
Ground thing here.
Okay, there's nothing here.
Anything on here?
No?
Anything down here?
What the fuck is this?
Where am...
Oh!
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
It's crucial to get the main...
Oh, okay.
So, we paint that.
That's a lot.
This wasn't at the start.
I didn't know you could lie on the internet.
That sounds so mean.
Okay, we did it.
I'm a hero.
Yeah.
Here is this.
Alright, we gotta save Goofy.
Alright.
How is it moving?
Oh, there it is.
That's where it's moving.
I was like wondering, like, where the fuck is the moving part in this game?
For the...
Monorail!
I wanna sing that song one day.
I'm gonna sing that at a concert.
I do a group song with a monorail song.
Monorail!
Alright.
Get out of here, chicken.
There can only be one robot chicken in this world.
Alright.
Nice!
We got his left leg.
My leg!
Oh yeah, Disney owns the Simpsons now.
No, technically you don't need to get a license.
Uh...
For, like, song...
I mean...
If it's, like, performed in the concert, I don't think so.
I don't know.
Maybe...
Actually, don't take advice from me about, like, music laws.
I sort of fucked up, like...
So, like...
I messed up a bit with, like, one of the BGMs for...
Okay, so, um...
Okay, so, uh...
For the BGM for the summer outfit...
Oh, hey!
Wait, let me grab this.
Alright, so...
Not...
Hashtag not legal advice.
But for the BGM...
For this...
Like, the chatting screen for that...
So, like...
You might notice I have to put description, uh...
Credit for it.
Um...
And, like...
Uh...
To put the credit for it and everything.
So, you know, I...
Obviously, because I bought the license for it.
So...
Um...
In one of the videos, I forgot to put the credit on it.
And then, so, like...
It got, like, marked because it's, like, an auto-scanner and everything.
Um...
It's an auto...
You know, like, when music companies, like, auto-scans for, like...
If it's, like, the credit is, like...
In the description.
So, I forgot to do that for one of the videos.
Because, like...
Usually, when I make the waiting room, um...
Um...
Sometimes it's not the outfit I decide to use.
So...
Uh...
Okay, I'm gonna stay here before...
Because I can't multitask right now.
So, basically, like...
Um...
For one of the streams, I forgot to put the credit in.
And then it got, like, you know, marked.
It's not a strike.
It just said, like, oh, you won't get monetization.
Um...
Because the monetization will...
The ad revenue will go to the copyright holder.
So, that repelled it.
I was, like...
Appealed it.
And I was, like...
Oh...
Sorry.
I bought the license for it.
I just forgot to take...
I just forgot to copy and paste the credit just to...
Into this description.
Um...
But it should be in there now.
And I did all that.
But then I didn't realize...
I forgot to press save on the description.
Ha ha ha ha!
On the vibe.
I forgot...
I did copy and paste it.
But I forgot to press save.
So then, like...
I was, like, oh, I'm sorry.
And then I...
My...
My appeal up...
Got rejected.
But then they're, like, you can appeal it again.
But...
If, like, it gets rejected again...
It's a strike on your channel!
Ha ha ha ha!
So...
Obviously...
I did it again.
But I...
This time...
It's in it.
I, like...
I sent an email to the creator.
I was like...
I'm so sorry!
Ha ha ha!
I forgot to put it in the description!
But it's in there now!
And I sent an email out.
Cause, like, they're like...
Oh!
If you have, like, any problems with it...
Please send us an email.
We'll try to get that fixed.
And then...
I sent it...
I sent an email...
I saved this time!
I...
Ha ha ha!
I saved the...
I sent an email...
I'll be like, I'm so sorry.
I...
I appealed it before.
I actually forgot to put it in... I forgot to press save in the description box.
But it's in there for real now.
Um, can you, like, look into this so I don't get the strength on my channel?
I'm living on the edge.
You know what's crazy, though?
Like, it's not even that much ad revenue.
I'm pretty...
Like, I'm pretty sure it's, like, ten whole...
Ten whole dollars to play with me.
Ten whole dollars for a mid...
That's, like, saying, like...
It's, like, maybe...
That's, like, me being hopeful at ten dollars.
That's, like, the high end of my ad...
The ad revenue for that video.
I'm, like, playing...
I'm gambling with my channel right now.
I, like...
I, like, risking it all for ten whole dollars of ad revenue.
It's not about the money.
All the money is money.
I'm risking it all for ten dollars.
And my entire channel is for ten whole dollars.
Your life is on the line.
Let's go gambling.
All right.
Let's see.
We go this way.
Oh, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum.
Oh, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum,
ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum For five dollars.
Next to you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I try to help and generally do not mean to mislead you.
Don't keep upset on the first stream.
I get laughed.
Wait, what?
Wait.
I don't even remember that.
Don't worry, Alex.
I laugh at everybody.
Don't worry.
Okay, wait.
What is he doing?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
He's beating up the fucking monkey.
I mean, is that legal?
Look, he's dead.
Bro, he's dead.
Where's the ref?
Where the fuck is he?
Guys, ref, where the fuck?
He's dead.
Please.
Someone stop him.
He's dead.
Okay.
Bro, he won't tap out.
Please.
He's dead.
Someone stop.
Oh shit.
Wait, that hurts me.
Nah, you didn't box it anymore.
He didn't hear no bell.
Where the fuck is the ref?
All right, here we go.
I entered the space voyage.
Fight back.
There are pipes we need to repair in there.
It's rotating.
Great.
Beetleworks Tinker can fire barrage with thinner paint.
And it's guarding the elevator.
The one we need to ride atop of space voyage.
Oh, hey.
There's a hen.
Let me think.
When those pistons are working in sequence, you can climb them to the elevator.
I got it.
Now you can take through the people's mover.
Avoid the electric fence.
Find and break down the hatch.
Then repair.
Jesus Christ.
That was so easy.
Wow.
Wow, sir.
That sounded so fucking easy.
Oh my god.
Excuse me?
I have to do what and what and also what now?
What's over here?
What do I do?
Oh, shit.
Where is it taking me?
Where am I?
Oh, shit.
That's where I am.
I was like, where the fuck is this taking me?
This is not part of the plan that this guy gave me.
He's like, you're supposed to do this and that.
And then I'm like, see ya.
Well, I'll go here instead.
Alright.
Where am I?
Actually, where am I?
TV.
What did I do?
Okay.
Where was that?
Oh, it's over there.
How did I get there, though?
I have so many questions.
Okay, so I have to go down from here.
And then...
Clearly...
Oh, shit.
I did not mean to put a TV there.
Really?
That's something?
There's something down here?
There.
I hear something.
Oh, there he is.
I know.
Get out of here.
I can shut down one of the viewers' generator.
Or I can give you three TVs.
Uh...
No, I don't need a TV.
Yeah, you know what?
No, that's easier.
No.
Yeah, that's easy.
That's a lot easier.
Yeah, break that thing.
Okay.
We, uh...
Free TV sounds cool.
Guys, we don't need another TV, guys.
I know how to get back up top, though.
Friend.
That's right.
And he'll never know.
He'll never know I forced him to be my friend.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm a little confused right now.
But I got spirit.
What's this?
Nice.
How do I get the other...
Oh, there it is.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, no.
Actually, how do I...
How do I get back?
Ow.
Okay, I'm, like, clearly shorter than this.
Okay, this way.
Okay, I need to do this, too.
But...
How do I get that part?
That has to be, like...
The goofy part, too.
Okay.
This is fine.
This?
Can I thin that?
That seems thinnable.
Right?
No?
Okay.
I'm confused, but I have spirit.
Go this way.
Hello.
Oh, I have to go down from here.
Okay.
Okay, before we do that, though...
There is...
Okay, wait.
I can go down from here.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
He was, like, just naked.
Without me being there.
Fucking freaky.
Freaky ass chickens.
He was, like, naked with all the other chickens.
So fucking freaky.
Hey, you saw that?
I dropped down.
He was already naked.
And he was, like, oh my god.
It's not for you.
And then he put his clothes back on.
Yeah.
Freaky ass chicken.
And this was their private time.
That's messed up, Doki.
You interrupted their private time.
Freaky ass chicken.
Wait, what?
How do I get in...
How do I get there?
Wait.
How do I get that part?
I got a sketch, though.
I got a rocket.
Wait, that's clearly...
You can do that.
What does this do?
What did it do?
Oh, this.
I was, like...
Where is it taking me?
Oh, nice.
I got an arm, though.
Got your arm.
There's a clamp I can thin.
Oh, shit.
That's...
Oh, that's the wrong one.
Sorry.
I meant to be here.
I was looking at the wrong one.
Whoops.
Okay, now I got...
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's Pluto's dog tag.
I got your nose.
Oh, I got, like, an extra quest.
Okay, we got, uh...
We got to go...
You know what?
I'm tired of this outfit.
I want to change clothes.
I want me Steamboat Willie now.
Because I'm public domain, baby.
Oh, I didn't give it to Horace in Main Street?
What is he gonna do with it?
Is it his freaky time?
Is that...
Why Horace?
What is he gonna do with the collar?
Is it supposed to come down?
Oh, there it is.
He misses his wife.
Alright, up I go.
Yay!
I go up now.
Alright.
Oh, I hear you.
I can stop one, be the worst, share, give you three TVs.
I already have three TVs.
And then, where the fuck are all of these two?
I feel like I'm not bumped into any of these generators.
Is that it?
Is that all there is?
Yeah.
Where does this go?
What the fuck am I supposed to be doing up here?
I guess that was it.
Ah, okay.
Alright.
That was easy.
Okay.
Is this part of it?
Hello?
Whoa!
No!
Stop!
Bad!
Stop being bad!
Get a hobby!
There's more to life than being an anti!
Stop!
Oh, shit!
Yeah.
Get a life!
Alright, that should kill him.
Nice!
Yay!
You don't understand the absolute joy about being an anti!
A bro is dedicated!
He doesn't care!
He was dedicated until the end.
Is something wrong?
Yeah, on the Moonliner rocket, a gremlin told me the mad doctor sabotaged it.
This thing parsed for his terrible machines.
I should never let him build those be.
When he stood apart, did he say nyah-ha-ha?
Nyah-ha-ha.
Yeah, he didn't.
Why?
Nyah-ha-ha always means bad news.
Listen, Mouse, you have to recover those stolen rocket parts.
One part is being held by Petronic.
Start with him.
Others are Lonesome Manor and Tortuga.
Tortuga?
Wait, that's like...
Where's Tortuga?
Wait, no.
That's from a movie, right?
Meet me at Mickey Junk Mountain.
Where is that?
That's so familiar.
Is that Pius the Caribbean?
Yeah, it's like... That's so familiar.
I gotta go to Tortuga.
It's the next rocket piece you need.
Oh my god, it is Tron!
Hurry up and grab it as soon as you can.
Uh-huh!
Okay.
Petronic?
Where are you?
Hello?
You seem like a very nice guy.
Welcome to Space Voyage, Mickey.
Hope you're ready to see stars if you get my drift.
Say hello to Petronic.
I am master of this arena.
And with my argumentations, you ain't got a chance, Mickey.
I always win here.
I need to defeat Petronic or Brefenin, Mickey.
FRIEND!
Oh my god, guys.
I don't know if it's working.
Guys, I cannot tell.
I...
Oh no.
Oh no, I ran out of...
Oh.
Oh, that might not be a friend thing.
Oh wait, no.
It is!
Oh, okay.
Okay, I just gotta fill it up.
Here we go.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
Oh my god, he's blue now.
I think we're best friends.
Cause that's what best friends do, right?
We just do a little...
Sometimes we hit each other.
That's what best friends do.
Sometimes you gotta force feed them some friendship juice.
Sometimes you gotta force your friend to ingest some friendship juice.
If they know what's good for them.
FRIEND!
FRIEND Frisbee!
Ultimate Frisbee!
FRIEND!
What is ZZ?
It's just three strikes.
It's Mario lost.
Oh my god, he missed, stupid.
Okay.
Friendship this time.
Ultimate Frisbee.
Take my juice, Pete.
Okay.
Okay, that's not good, but that's okay.
Oh shit.
It's like Pong.
But like, for babies.
Oh my god, it is like Pong.
Alright, come on.
Do a thing.
Haha, that's Rookie, right?
Haha, oh shit.
Haha, that's right.
Alright.
Ultimate Frisbee time.
Three strikes and you're out.
Yay!
That's it.
Show this back as friendship juice.
Friend!
Yay!
Wow, I lost my head for a while.
Here, take this disc, will ya?
I don't need it anymore.
I'm gonna see if I can get tomorrow's city cleaned up.
Tell Big Bad Pete I said hi, will ya?
Yay!
With a black shot in my friendship juice.
You redeemed Petronic.
He's very powerful and I'll use that power to help Wasteland.
Hurrah!
Your paint or thinner capacity can change based on how you deal with important characters in Wasteland.
Yay!
Friendship is magic!
Let's fire the rocket.
Yippee!
Collected all the rocket parts.
Let's go.
Yes.
That's a good friend.
See?
He enjoyed it.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
The OGTV sketch used to have the now public domain steamboat Mickey whistling on them.
Oh, that's cool.
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Hey, Mouse.
It's about time you showed up.
The next rocket part to find is in Venture Line.
But the projector screen is out of order.
Gremlin Marcus is the only one who can fix it.
But he's been tracked by splatters.
Wait, they're here?
You're gonna need to help him.
I'd do it myself.
I'll see how- just how you'll handle the situation.
Get to it.
Wait, how did he get here?
What the fuck?
They're in Mean Street?
This is my sit- city.
Get out of here.
Friendship!
Okay, we just got- Forced to be friends with one last guy.
Yeah.
Now everyone is okay now.
Thank you so much, Mickey.
Meet me back at the pen- The Penny Arcade.
I feel safer there.
Alright.
We gotta talk to a horse, right?
One of the dog tags.
He's over there.
Man, that's a throwback.
Someone took a special flower from Clarabelle's window sill in Oztown.
Some, it just seems like a stupid flower.
But Clarabelle grew of it, so me, it's important.
Can't really be around Clarabelle about getting clumsy.
Will you track it down?
Check around our windows for clues.
Okay, but...
One of my clients want to know what happened to his cousin.
They're supposed to return to Venture Line with the others, but never made it.
We were heading out.
Can we try to find out what happened?
This is great news.
Now I have a lead.
I can't pay much right now.
I hope you find some use for this power spark.
Okay.
Alright, so...
We gotta find Clarabelle's...
Uh...
Clarabelle's...
Thing.
But that's okay.
You know what?
Uh...
We'll call it here.
Cause I just say today's gonna be a short stream today.
Sorry for not doing a long stream today.
But I'll do a super chat reading a little bit though.
Um...
But...
We'll stop here.
I think we'll stop here.
Did you get...
No, I...
Are they all in the...
Uh...
All in the...
What is it?
Tomorrow then?
But we'll stop here.
I think this is a good stopping point.
I think it's saved, right?
I...
I hope it's saved.
But we'll...
Just cause...
I have a lot of work to do.
I have a lot of work to do behind the scenes.
Uh...
Since yesterday I...
I didn't do a lot.
Whoa!
No, it's fine.
We'll give it to him later.
It's okay.
I'm pretty sure...
I think it's saved.
I'm pretty sure.
I...
Hehehehehehe.
Um...
Let me...
Put...
A super chat reading.
Guys.
Nippee!
Wait...
Where's the...
Where's the text?
Whoa!
I got his...
Freak time.
No, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
Do a short stream today.
Um...
Just cuz I actually have a lot of work to do today.
And I wanna be...
Make sure that dad...
Is okay for...
Is okay...
Throughout the days.
So I can monitor him throughout the night.
But I hope you guys had a fun time hanging out with me for Epic Mickey.
I'm sorry we didn't stream a lot of Epic Mickey today.
But don't worry, the next Epic Mickey stream will be a long one.
I promise.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're not back shouting my enemies.
We're waiting for my friends.
Life lessons with Doki Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let me...
Let me open my super chats.
I think I read most of them.
But just to be safe.
Just to be safe.
I just want to be sure.
Belthier!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Saw your donation to IDF.
This is one of many reasons you're based and goaded.
Kamiyoshi.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it too, guys.
I really do.
Abraham, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki Bird.
Hope everything is okay with you and your friends.
Never forget that you're most loved and respected VTuber.
The VTubering speaker has to offer.
Keep being awesome and keep taking great care of Dad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just hope that, you know, I just hope that, you know, I'm in a huge patch that, you know, I'll still have the drag wounds here with me, an audience with me.
Um, and I hope just want to make you guys laugh for as long as I can.
That's really all it managed to me.
I just want to have a great experience with my drag wound community.
Um, and create many, many, many great memories with all of you guys.
Yeah.
I always try to challenge myself too.
I always want to do new things.
Um, not just like...
I don't like coasting in general.
So that's why I always try to do new things.
New exciting things.
And, um, things to explore with my channel.
And I hope you guys are along with the ride.
Um, yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad, my beloved.
Nexi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, Fiction.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gears of War E-Day isn't coming until November of 26th.
And Reloaded is just a remaster of a remaster.
The thing I'm looking forward to is Dying Light the Beast.
And I hope you'll play it too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just make sure to not stand behind someone tall.
In your case, anyone over 5'6".
Anyone over 5'4", is like...
fucked up for me.
I just hope...
I just hope I can see what the fuck is going on at the Miku concert.
That's... that's all... that's all I hope for.
I hope I'll be able to see.
Like, I... I just hope that the adrenaline will like...
will...
um...
let me like...
get past like standing there for an hour.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'll tell more about my step-mom.
Okay, so...
Um...
It was like...
Okay, I... I don't know if I told my...
a story about my family before.
About like my extended family.
But like...
Have I ever told you guys about my step-grandma?
Sorry, not my step-mom.
My step-grandma.
I don't have a step-mom.
Uh...
But have I told you guys my story about my step-grandma?
Not a lot.
Okay, so...
Um...
My step-grandma...
tries to buy...
my love...
and also...
or try to buy my love...
and also like my cousin...
my other cousins as well.
So...
Uh...
Basically...
my grandpa...
remarried...
Like...
This is like really fucked up.
Okay...
This is a long time ago.
So like...
Don't worry guys.
Like...
It's a...
I've like...
Don't worry guys.
lived through it already.
So...
I've already like...
processed it.
Um...
So...
It was like...
You know...
The family drama...
of like...
affairs...
and stuff.
So...
My step-grandma...
had an affair...
with my grandpa.
And then...
my...
grandma...
passed away.
Um...
And so...
my grandpa...
married...
my step-grandma...
And like...
Thing is...
My step-grandma...
was...
Um...
Or is...
I don't know.
I don't...
I think she's alive.
Because she's...
Thing is...
She is like...
around the same age...
as my...
oldest uncle.
So...
I'm sure she's still alive.
I...
So...
She is...
around the same...
Like...
She is like...
maybe a couple years older...
than my...
My...
My uncle...
Um...
So...
This is so...
I can't even process what...
So...
Um...
So yeah...
So...
When...
My...
So then...
You know...
When I first came back...
To...
When I first like...
You know...
Came back to...
The...
China...
Not first, sorry.
When I...
Officially...
Moved back to Asia...
Um...
After living in Canada...
Of course...
You know...
My parents were like...
Say...
Mama...
And I was like...
What?
Who is...
I was just like...
I was like...
That's your...
Mama...
Which is Grandma...
Uh...
So I was...
So confused.
Because I was like...
Who is she?
Like...
I was like...
I'm so confused.
That was like...
No...
Um...
We went to my grandma's funeral.
That's not it.
Like, so I was just like...
No,
it's Popo and Mama.
I think Popo is, like, my mom's side.
And then Mama is my dad's side.
So...
So, I was so confused, because I was like, what do you mean?
Yeah, so I was like...
So, I was so...
And then, so that's when I realized...
Oh, it's...
And then my mom, like, took me to the side.
She's like, your grandpa remarried.
And I was like, oh...
And she's like...
And they're like, your grandpa remarried.
This is your new grandma now.
And I was like, oh, okay.
So...
Anyway...
The thing is...
Uh, I was very easy to please.
Because, like...
You know...
I was from Canada.
So, like, um...
I was very easy to please.
The other cousins don't really care about her.
But for me...
Since I grew up in Canada, I didn't really know much about my extended family.
So, uh... So, like, they can buy me some... My step-grandma would buy me gifts and stuff.
Because they'll be like, oh, here's some... Like, I'll take you to the bookstore and get you some gifts.
And I'll be like, yay!
I love you, mama!
You know, I was like, freestyle!
You know?
Yay!
And they're like, oh, yeah, you want these?
What do you like?
And she was like, you know...
She loves designer stuff.
So, she always had, like, Louis Vuitton bags.
She always had, like, Louis Vuitton bags.
And, like, you know, designer clothes and everything.
And she loved shopping for clothes and stuff.
And then she'd be like, do you want this?
And I'd be like, yeah!
This child can be bribed.
Yeah.
And I was like, yeah!
So, that's why I got the Chanel sneakers.
Because I was very easily bribed as a child.
I still am.
But, like, she, like, basically my step-grandma, like, tried to buy my love and succeeded.
She...
She very much succeeded in doing so.
Um...
Yay!
I love you, grandma!
It's very...
Very effective.
Uh...
So, that's basically...
Um...
That... I mean, there was more.
It was like...
It was a...
My... Oh, my gosh.
Um...
It was crazy.
My extended family was, like, an actual soap opera drama.
Sometimes.
Like...
Okay.
But then, like, the thing is...
It made my other cousins hate me, too.
Because of how...
Because, like, my grandma really liked...
My step-grandma...
Like, I was like, my grandma.
My step-grandma really liked me.
Because, like, I didn't give her any shit.
You know?
Like, you know?
Obviously...
Obviously, like, the other uncles and aunts...
Like, I have, like, an uncle and an aunt on my dad's side.
So, obviously, like...
My uncle and aunt and, like, the cousins, too...
Did not like her that much.
Um...
But she did try to buy their love, too.
She tried to buy their love.
Um...
But, like, it wasn't as effective as me.
Because, like, I also didn't, like...
Play into the whole drama situation.
Because I literally just came...
I came back from Canada.
Like, I don't fucking know what's going on...
About the inner politics of my family.
Like, I was a child...
And I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
I was just like...
Free stuff!
Yeah!
I love you, grandma!
Like...
Like, what the fuck?
I was a child.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
Like, I got gifts.
That's, like...
That's great.
Like...
I literally got fucking ripped...
And relocated...
From a place that I lived for 10 years.
And then I have to, like...
Like, fucking try and...
Socially adjust to everything.
Like, I mean, like...
That was, like, the joy...
Like, the one of the little joys in my life.
Like...
Anyway...
So, like...
Later on...
My cousins didn't like me.
My cousins and my...
My aunt and uncle sort of didn't really like me.
Because I was also, like...
My step-grandma...
And my grandpa's, like...
Favorite...
Grandchild.
Because, like...
I was very, like...
I was very studious person.
And at that time...
And also at that time...
I also was in, like...
Sport teams and stuff.
So I was, like, in varsity and stuff.
And I actually won, like...
Medals and stuff for those things.
So then, like, my mom would always, like, show them off to them.
They're like, look at that!
And everything!
Look at this!
And that!
And then, like, so... And I also loved when my... my... um... My step-grandma would take me to, like, some bookstores.
Like, she'll take me to this, like, big bookstore that will actually have English books.
Um, because, like, um, at that time, it was so hard to find any English books to buy unless you go to Hong Kong.
So, like, she actually took me to this giant bookstore that actually had, like, English books and stuff.
So that made me really happy.
And I would buy English books.
And I would be happy with English books, too.
Like, like, I, like, like, she would successfully bribe me with cheap items, and it worked.
Because, like, at that time, I was desperate for, like, anything English that I could read.
Um, or, like, consume, you know?
Like, I was like...
Because, like, um, at that time, like, I didn't know VPN.
Like, at that time, like, I didn't know much about VPNs or stuff like that.
So you can imagine, like, a lot of websites are blocked, too.
So, like, I didn't have, like, YouTube or, like, you know, I didn't have YouTube or, like, really much of a way to, like, consume, like, English media.
Um, and so, like, being able to actually, like, you know, have English media to consume back then at a younger age was, like, really good for me.
And I, uh, uh, and, uh, um, and I was, like, super happy about that.
So, like, my grandma, my step-grandma realized, oh, I can just bribe her with cheap books.
Instead of designer items.
Because she would bribe, she would bribe my aunts, my aunts and uncles with designer items and stuff.
And cousins, too, with expensive gifts.
And then later on, she realized, like, I don't need that because, like, I'm from Canada.
And so, like, it was very easy to buy my love.
So she's, like, wow, I can just buy her books and she'll be happy.
And she was right.
And, like, she would have to buy, like, Louis Vuitton bags and stuff for my aunts and uncles.
Or, like, my uncle's wife and stuff.
She would have to buy, like, designer clothes or designer bags for them to make them satisfied.
Um, and then for me, it's just, I just like, three books, please.
And she'll be, like, wow.
So, anyway, as I got older.
Um, my grandma, my step-grandma, uh, my step-grandma was, like, chastising my uncle's wife and his kid.
Because, like, um, I was the first grandchild with my, like, with my dad's last name.
So I was the first grandchild for that.
So, like, the first grandchild with my grandpa's last name.
Um, there was other grandchildren ahead of me that were older than me.
But they were from my, um, they were from my aunt.
So, obviously, my aunt took, like, her husband's name.
So they weren't considered, like, you know, they don't have the, uh, my grandpa's last name.
So, I was the first grandchild with my grandpa's last name.
And, but my uncle, um, my, my uncle had, uh, had the son.
Had a son.
So, like, you know, he's the firstborn grandchild who's, like, who's, uh, who's male.
Who's also had, who also has, like, my grandpa's last name.
And, obviously, like, tier-wise, he's considered a higher tier than me.
Um, but then, the thing is, um, um, the thing is, um, uh, when I got older and he got older, uh, he was around the age, he was around the age that I, he was turning around the age that I was when I first moved, uh, to, to, to China, um, and, uh, my step-grandma and my grandpa would,
like, judge him and be like, when Toki was your age, all she did was read.
She was so studious.
And she won, like, trophies and medals, uh, from school.
Where is your trophies and medals?
Why aren't you reading like her?
I was, yeah, I was, yeah, I was that cousin.
Yeah, and then, and then my uncle's wife hated me because of it.
I was like, what did I do?
I'm just, I'm sorry for existing.
Like, oh, yeah, I'm sorry.
Like, I, what the fuck did I do?
Like, like, so, it was you who knew it.
You're that cousin.
So, um, so, like, my uncle's wife hated me because of that.
Because her child kept being compared to me when I was his age.
Uh, so, uh, can you...
I, what the fuck?
I, I'm sorry.
I just, I had nothing to do in school.
I wanted to do stuff.
Like, you...
Like, I was so bored.
Of course I joined sports teams.
I was so bored.
I didn't know what to do with my time.
But, yeah, so that's like a little bit of a little bit of an inside look into my life.
But, yeah.
Um...
How do they blame me?
I don't fucking know!
Like, I'm sorry!
You could read too!
Like...
By the way, he grew up as an iPad kid.
So that's not my fault.
That's not my fucking fault that their kid grew up to be an iPad kid.
Like...
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can't believe you went from getting bribed by books to not even being able to read.
The VTuber debuff is real.
Doe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I saw what you did.
You're a giga chat.
Just thought you should know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Seijin, thank you for the magenta stickers.
Bae, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe that Doki used to be a successful cousin from all the C- Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I was... Did I tell you guys this?
I was the first kid to be... to have an education outside of China.
So I was the first one.
On my dad's side.
Not on my mom's side.
But on my dad's side, I was the first one to be born outside.
And also, like... Also, like... Have an education outside of China, too.
That's why, like... When I came back, I had to go to international school.
Because, like... I was not gonna adjust.
I did not learn enough Chinese.
To, like... To, like, speak anything but English.
Like... I remember when... When I had... When I was in... When I came back.
I think I... I... It was the fifth...
Fifth grade.
Fifth grade was when I... When I started... School... When I started school in Asia.
So... And then they had to put me in, like... Because there's, like, you know... Chinese classes, too.
Um... There are Chinese classes.
So... There's, like... They do it in three different levels.
There's, like... Easy, Medium, and Hard.
And, like... They try... They... The teacher tried to put me in Hard.
Because they're, like... Oh... Like... Your family... Like... Speaks Chinese, right?
I was, like... Yeah, but, like... I grew up in Canada.
And then... He was, like... No, no, no.
You're fine.
And then he put me in... Hard... Difficulty.
Like, the hard... Difficulty for the class.
And, like... Nearly the first hour... He transferred... Like... The first, like... 15 to 20 minutes... He transferred me back to the middle class.
Because, like... I was, like... I don't fucking understand.
I was... He was, like... Okay, we're gonna... Blah, blah, blah.
And I was, like... What the fuck?
He did... I was not... Fine.
He, like... Transferred me... To the middle class.
And then I was just, like... The middle level.
And I was, like... Okay, this should be better, right?
I was, like... I don't... I was, like... I was, like...
I learned Cantonese.
Like...
Because, like... I was, like... I learned traditional.
So, I was just like, no.
Because I was like, right there, like, okay, show me what you can write.
So, I was writing.
Like, I was writing.
And then it was like, I used...
I learned traditional characters, which is different from simplified.
And they're like, no, this is right.
And I was like, what do you mean it's right?
Like, this is what I learned.
And then they're like, wait.
And I was like, I...
They're like, wait, do you not know, like, men?
And I was like, I learned...
I grew up learning Cantonese.
And then they transferred me to the easy class.
Because they're like, oh.
Yeah, we're gonna have to start new for this one.
For this child.
I didn't even know there were two different types.
I didn't even know there was a simplified.
I didn't grow up with that.
I went in Canada.
I had Chinese classes, too.
But we learned in traditional.
And we're speaking Cantonese.
And then I didn't even realize there was...
There was like...
There was the what?
I didn't even realize it divided between traditional and simplified.
I didn't even realize that.
I was so young.
And that's when I learned.
Wait, I was like, oh, they're simplified?
Because they're like, you're right.
You're not so...
It's like...
You're supposed to use simplified.
And I was like, what do you mean I'm supposed to use simplified?
What does that mean?
What does simplified mean?
I was so confused in fifth grade.
And then...
So then they transferred me to the easy class.
Because I was like...
I don't know what's going on.
I was so...
I was so confused.
Because my dad refused to speak in...
Not refused.
He was like...
He was like, it's okay.
She'll just learn.
They're like, it's okay.
She doesn't have to learn both languages.
We'll just talk in Cantonese instead of Mandarin.
Because my mom...
My mom is from Hong Kong.
And my dad is from Shenzhen.
So like...
So like, my dad speaks both Cantonese and Mandarin.
But my mom can only speak Cantonese.
She can listen Mandarin.
But she can't speak Mandarin.
So then like, when I was growing up...
My dad was like, to make it easier for everybody...
We'll just teach her Cantonese.
To make it easier for the family.
So, because you know...
So like...
Since it's what only my...
My dad can only speak Mandarin.
So then...
I grew up just...
I grew up for the first 10 years of my life.
Speaking Cantonese.
And listening to Cantonese.
And so like...
I didn't realize like...
You know...
I didn't realize that Mandarin existed for the first 10 years of my life.
Because I was so...
That's why I was so confused.
I was so fucking confused when I like...
Because even in school...
Even when I was in school in Canada.
We also learned Cantonese.
And like...
Because it was like...
We also learned Cantonese.
And we were like traditional too.
We're also writing in traditional.
So I was so fucking confused.
So then when I moved to Asia.
And then I went to school in...
In...
International school.
And we had like Chinese classes and stuff.
They're like...
Everybody was speaking like...
Learning Mandarin and stuff like that.
Like simplified and...
Mandarin.
And then like...
Obviously, you know...
I heard everybody speaking Mandarin.
My grandpa...
My grandpa speaks Mandarin.
My step-grand...
My entire family...
My...
Okay.
That's...
This is the weird part.
My grandpa speaks Mandarin.
So does my step-grandma.
But my uncle and aunt...
Aunt's and...
My uncles and aunts on my dad's side.
Can speak Cantonese.
And Mandarin.
But then my cousins...
Can only speak Mandarin.
So it was so fucking confusing.
Like for me.
When I was there.
It was so confusing.
Because my uncles and aunts...
Would speak Cantonese to me.
Like...
But then my cousins...
Would speak Mandarin to me.
And then my grandpa and step-grandma...
So like...
It was...
It was just all over the place.
But the thing is...
I didn't grow up with Mandarin too.
So I was so confused.
Like...
Adjusting to everything.
Um...
Yeah.
And then...
Um...
But yeah.
Anyway.
So...
Um...
So when I was in...
Fifth grade.
They first put me in the heart.
So anyway.
In conclusion.
Um...
They try to put me in a hard class.
Because they're like...
Oh, your family.
Um...
Like...
Oh, your family speaks Chinese.
I was like...
Yeah.
And...
But I was like...
Well, like...
I only know how to speak Cantonese.
I was like...
Uh...
Sounds like that.
I was like...
Struggling so hard.
Um...
Six...
And I keep up.
I was like...
Well...
Because there was...
One of the teachers.
Because there's three teachers there.
The easy, medium, hard.
So one of the teachers.
I think it was the...
One of the teachers actually knew how to...
Speak Cantonese.
So she was like...
Oh, okay.
Like...
So she was like...
Okay.
We'll test you out in the hard class first.
Alright.
We'll test you out.
I was like...
And then they were like...
Okay.
We're putting you in medium.
And they're like...
Okay.
We're putting you in the easy class.
And then the funny thing is that...
Everyone in the easy class...
Were...
Were white people.
So...
I was like...
I think I was the only Asian...
I was the only Asian in the EZ class, because the others were from America.
I'm from Canada, so technically, I was literally the only Asian in the EZ class, too.
The others were the international students from America or Europe.
So, yeah.
The medium and hard classes were, like, you know, like, I remember, like, one of my best friends back then, like, she's Korean, and she was in the hard class, too.
And she knew more Chinese than me.
I remember in fifth grade, she could, like, her Chinese was so much better than mine.
Like, she had to help me translate sometimes back then.
But obviously, I got better, because I literally, like, lived there for so long.
I didn't know that.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Her name?
I'm not doxing.
But her Chinese name was Jinju.
And I was like, wow, that's such a pretty name.
Because that means pearl in Chinese.
That means pearl in Chinese.
And, um, I was like, oh, that's so cute.
I was like, wow.
And she's like, thanks, I picked it.
I was just like...
I was like...
And then at that time, when I was little, I was like...
What?
You can just do that?
I was like, you picked your own Chinese name?
I was like...
Because she's, like...
Because she's Korean.
So, because, like, you know, when she...
When she's going to international school, like, you know, they have a Chinese name, too.
So she's like, oh, I'm going to be pearl.
And I was like, you can just do that?
You can just pick a Chinese name?
I was born with my name.
And I was so confused.
I...
I'm so...
I'm so fucking confused.
I mean, yeah.
Yeah, I was like, wait.
How come your name is pearl?
Like, my name means nothing in Chinese.
Just so you guys know.
How do you say...
Lean.
I know, like, how to say it in Cantonese.
But I don't remember how to pronounce it in Mandarin.
For Chinese.
Yeah, man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
I was like, what?
But yeah, no.
My...
Apparently, my name means nothing.
Um...
It just, like, sounds nice.
That's really it.
Because, like, I remember.
Because, like...
The reason why, like...
We were talking about name meanings...
Is because our Chinese teacher...
Well, not our.
Well, we were just, like, hanging out.
I don't know why we were, like, in the Chinese classroom.
Oh, yeah.
Because, like, everyone has the same class.
Like, we're all just divided into different tables and stuff.
So, um...
I was hanging out with my friend back then.
Like, my best friend in fifth grade.
And, like...
Or was it recessed?
I think it was recessed.
There's no way.
Because I'm pretty sure it's not...
We weren't divided into different tables.
Because we had to go to different classrooms.
But, um...
It might have been recessed or break.
And we're hanging out in one of the Chinese classrooms.
And we're talking about name meanings.
Like, our meaning...
The meaning of our names.
And then, like...
The Chinese teacher was, like...
Oh, yes.
Your name means this.
And your name means that.
And then, like...
I was, like...
Oh, that's so cool.
And then, like...
Oh, your name means pearl.
Like, to my friend.
And then I was like, oh, that's so cool.
What does my name mean?
And he was like, nothing.
I was like, what?
It's like, oh, it doesn't mean anything.
Like, what do you mean my name doesn't mean anything?
And I asked my parents about it.
I was like, my teacher told me my name doesn't mean anything.
And then my mom was like, yeah, when you were born, your grandma gave us a list of Chinese names to pay.
And like, it's like... apparently, it's like... because like the number of strokes also means something in your Chinese name.
I don't remember what it was, but... it has like the number of strokes in your name also means something.
And then they're like, okay, pick from this list.
My actual grandma, not my step-grandma.
My actual grandma.
And then they're like, oh, this one, because it sounds the nicest.
I'm like, this sounds the nicest.
So, we're going to pick that one.
I'm just like, okay.
Gavin,nya10, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't know your name after that one character from Hunter x Hunter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because apparently, it sounds nice, but it has no meaning to it.
But sometimes... some... some names actually... some people actually name their kids with actual meaning to their names.
But mine is just... it just sounds nice, but there's no meaning to it.
And I guess it has a good amount of strokes.
Like, good number... like, good brush strokes.
I don't know.
They named you pearly off of vibes.
Okay.
I won't like... this is not really doxing, but my... my name... my English name is, like, based... is named after one of... like, a celebrity.
I'll just say that.
My mom, when she was trying to name me, um...
When she was... she's like, this celebrity's name sounds nice.
And then she...
She was... it was named after... she's like, one day...
You'll be... you'll be a celebrity, too.
You're Beyonce?
Yeah, that's how... my name... my... my mom was really like...
My mom was really like...
Oh, man.
This celebrity's name sounds nice.
Like...
One day you'll be...
rich and famous and a celebrity, too.
Little did she know.
I can't believe she was right.
I did become infamous.
Will Smith?
Oh, my God!
Doki!
You're... you're...
Doki Will Smith Bird?
Uh...
Um...
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you ever looked down...
Chinese names or decided?
I did...
It's wild.
Well, for me, it was just...
My grandma gave a list and then my mom picked...
Picked a name.
Um...
All right.
I'm gonna call it here.
It was nice chatting with all of you guys.
I had a great time doing my little Zatsa down here.
And giving you guys some...
Uh...
Some little, like, lore drops here and there.
About, like, my past and my family.
But I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me.
Um...
I had a great time talking to you guys, too.
Uh...
I'm gonna go do some work stuff now.
And, like, focus on catching up on some behind-the-scenes work.
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get your blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause...
You does have it.
Also, buy my merch.
Uh...
The merch store is still...
The birthday merch is still there.
I believe the pre-orders for birthday merch will end at...
Around August the 4th.
Um...
But...
I think you can pre-order it still until the stocks run...
Until the, like, extra stock runs out that we're gonna order.
But anyway...
Uh...
See you guys later, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
Secret ending.
Because...
I was pinged about something.
Give me a sec.
What the fuck is...
Oh, my.
Give me a sec.
Guys.
Fucker.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Zero point...
Sixty-nine.
Alright.
Give me a sec, guys.
Guys.
LOL LOL Wait, no.
Nice.
I'll do that.
Alright.
You'll understand.
You'll understand when you see it.
No!
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Apparently, minimum is one dollar.
So, like, this is, like, the best I could do.
Apparently, I have to do a minimum one dollar.
We were like, what the fuck is going on?
Don't worry.
There was a tweet.
I'm being antagonized right now.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I have to send a code to myself real quick.
Alright.
I'm not moving because I have to look at... I have a two-factor for my PayPal.
Wait.
Uh... Oh, wait.
What?
Did I not send a code?
What the fuck is my code?
How the fuck am I supposed to do... Okay.
Send new code, please.
Send.
What the fuck is my code?
How am I supposed to do this PayPal shit?
Oh, is it my phone?
Oh, my God.
It's my phone.
I don't... I'm not receiving, like, actual connection right now.
I hate my office so much.
I... I hate my office so much sometimes.
My... Give me a sec, guys.
My code is not working.
Don't... Okay.
Alright.
No.
I received it.
That's right.
How did... Were you pinged as well that what I was gonna do?
That's okay, right?
That's right.
Let's see.
For a good cause.
And I'll be on top.
That's right.
I have two cents in my PayPal balance.
And also...
And also, just enough.
That's right.
Refresh that shit.
Wait.
Nice.
There we go.
Alright.
This is fine.
There you go.
For those who are confused, you can...
Now you guys know.
For those who were very confused.
Wait.
Alright.
Let me...
Let me tweet this real quick.
And just be like, lol.
No, actually, I got a better idea.
Okay.
Doki donating a dollar to be over a minute...
She did it first!
What do you mean?
If anything, she started it!
She did it first!
There we go.
She started it!
If anything, I'm just going...
I'm just...
Getting my rightful position back.
Number five.
There we go.
Alright.
And also, I'll link it too.
For a good cause.
It's for a good cause.
Alright.
There we go.
Alright, I'll see you guys later.
Bye.
For real.